I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello everyone. Hey!
我是珍娜·费舍，我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，也是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女郎。大家好。嘿！
We are going to business school today. Oh, you guys, it's going to be so fun. We might get our frizz on. I wouldn't know anything about that. You're going to know everything about it because you and I have a frothing date. I can't wait to froth with you. I'm going to chunk it at you, lady. Oh, boy.
我们今天要上商学院了。哦，伙计们，这会非常有趣。我们可能会变得狂热起来。我对那个一无所知。你会对它了如指掌，因为你和我有一个狂欢的约会。我迫不及待地想和你一起狂欢了。我要把它砸向你，女士。噢，天哪。
Guys, this is season three, episode 16, written by Brent Forrester and directed by Joss Whedon. I'm going to hit you with a summary. Do it. I wrote my summary really succinct today. Oh, it's so succinct that you had to call it out. I did. Hey, guys, get ready for some succinct summary. Oh, say that five times fast.
伙计们，这是第三季第16集，由布伦特·福雷斯特编剧，乔斯·韦登执导。我要用一个总结来打击你。动手吧。我今天写的总结非常简练。哦，简练到你不得不特意提出来。我确实提了。嘿，伙计们，准备好迎接一些简练的总结吧。哦，把这句话快速说五遍。
Ryan brings Michael to be a guest speaker at his business school. A bat causes mayhem at The Office. Jim pretends to be turning into Dracula to prank Dwight. Pam shows her art at an art exhibition. It sounds so simple, right? More simple sentences, and yet it is not simple at all. It's simple, but there's so much. I have one little thing to add.
瑞恩请迈克尔去他的商学院当客座演讲嘉宾。一只蝙蝠在办公室里引起了混乱。吉姆假装变成德古拉来恶作剧德怀特。帕姆在艺术展上展示她的艺术作品。听起来很简单，对吧？更多的简单句，然而它一点也不简单。很简单，但内容又非常丰富。我有一点小补充。
Brent says in the DVD commentary, he was handed two cards off the wall. You know, we've talked about how on the wall the writers have all these cards. Yeah. He was just handed two, three by five cards. One said business school and the other said bat in the office. Well, look at that. A succinct note card give to go along with my succinct summary. And I guess business school was Greg's idea.
布伦特在DVD评论音轨中说，他被塞了两张墙上的卡片。你知道的，我们讨论过编剧们在墙上有所有这些卡片。是的。他只是拿到了两张三乘五的卡片。一张写着商学院，另一张写着办公室里的蝙蝠。好吧，瞧瞧这个。一张与我的简练总结相配的简练索引卡。我想商学院是格雷格的主意。
He always knew at some point down the road he wanted to go to Ryan's business school. And I guess that card had been on the wall for a while. Well, Angela, speaking of bat storylines, fast fact number one, Joss Whedon directed this episode. So Joss is famous for creating Buffy the Vampire Slayer, the series starring Sarah Michelle Geller. A huge hit on the WB network, which was run at the time by Suzanne Daniels. Suzanne's husband is Greg Daniels.
他一直知道在未来的某个时候他想去瑞恩的商学院。我想那张卡片已经在墙上贴了一段时间了。好吧，安吉拉，说到蝙蝠的故事线，趣味事实一，乔斯·韦登执导了这一集。所以乔斯因创作《吸血鬼猎人巴菲》而闻名，这部由莎拉·米歇尔·盖拉主演的电视剧。在WB电视网大获成功，当时该电视网由苏珊·丹尼尔斯管理。苏珊的丈夫是格雷格·丹尼尔斯。
And that is how Joss kind of got his in to direct an episode of the show. But I guess it is just a pure coincidence that he got assigned the episode with a bat and a vampire storyline. I remember he was like, come on, guys, you gave me the bat vampire story. And we're like, and everyone was like, it is pure coincidence. Well, guys, we reach out to writer Brent Forrester. Remember, he sent in so many amazing audio clips for a grief counseling episode. He did it again this week.
这就是乔斯如何得到机会执导该剧某一集的原因。但我想他被分配到有蝙蝠和吸血鬼故事线的那一集纯属巧合。我记得他说过，拜托，伙计们，你们把蝙蝠吸血鬼的故事交给了我。我们当时就说，每个人都说，这纯属巧合。好吧，伙计们，我们联系了编剧布伦特·福雷斯特。记住，他为心理辅导那一集发了那么多精彩的音频片段。这周他又做了一次。
And here's what he had to say about this. This episode was directed by Joss Whedon, who was a big successful television creator at the time and happened to be a big fan of the office. And he approached us asking if he could direct an episode. He ended up directing two. And this was the first one that he did. And it's just a total coincidence that the first episode that he directed happens to have a vampire subplot in it.
以下是他对此的看法：这一集由乔斯·韦登执导，他当时是一位大型成功电视剧创作者，碰巧也是《办公室》的超级粉丝。他走过来问他是否可以导演一集。他最终导演了两集。这是他拍的第一部。他导演的第一集恰好有一个吸血鬼的情节，这纯属巧合。
And he was the creator of Buffy the Vampire Slayer. What you notice in that vampire subplot that I remember most is this visual detail that Joss added that was not in the script. If you notice at the end of the Jim Dwight vampire subplot, Jim says goodbye and leaves the office at the end of the day. And what he does, he turns and he flips up his collar and sort of looks over his shoulder. And it's the perfect image of Dracula looking over the corner of his cape. And it just works wonderfully as a visual gag, not in the script, totally the contribution
他曾是《吸血鬼猎人巴菲》的创作者。你在那个吸血鬼支线中注意到并让我印象最深的是乔斯添加的一个视觉细节，剧本中并没有。如果你注意到吉姆和德怀特的吸血鬼支线结束时，吉姆说再见并在一天结束时离开办公室。他所做的是，他转过身，竖起领子，有点回头看。这简直就是德古拉从他的斗篷角后面张望的完美形象。它作为一个视觉笑话效果极佳，不在剧本中，完全是一个
of a guy who has worked a long time in the vampire genre. That was pure Joss Whedon. I did not know that. I didn't know it either. And you remember at this time, because I asked Kent Sabornak about this as well, he said that after season two, after we won the Emmy, we had a bunch of directors reaching out about directing our show. Remember like Harold Ramis, J.J. Abrams, Jason Reitman?
在吸血鬼题材中工作了很长时间的人的贡献。那是纯粹的乔斯·韦登。我不知道这一点。我也不知道。而且你还记得这个时候，因为我也问过肯特·萨博纳克关于这的事，他说在第二季之后，在我们赢得艾美奖之后，有一堆导演联系我们想导演我们的节目。还记得像哈罗德·雷米斯、J·J·艾布拉姆斯、杰森·雷特曼吗？
Yes. So crazy. And Kent would just assign scripts according to director availability. And that is, he confirms how Joss got this episode. So now fast fact number two, location breakdown with Kentopedia. Oh, we need a jingle for location breakdown with Kentopedia. Location breakdown with Kentopedia. Do you like it?
是的。太疯狂了。肯特会根据导演的档期来分配剧本。这就是他证实乔斯是如何得到这一集的方式。现在是趣味事实二，肯特百科的取景地盘点。哦，我们需要一段肯特百科取景地盘点的顺口溜。肯特百科取景地盘点。你喜欢吗？
It's okay. I was trying to do like a schoolhouse rock thing. Yeah, I like it. Okay. Okay. Location breakdown with Kentopedia. Is this about Northridge? Yes.
还行。我当时想做一个学园摇滚（Schoolhouse Rock）风格的东西。是的，我喜欢。好吧。好吧。肯特百科取景地盘点。这是关于诺思里奇的吗？是的。
Okay. We had a fan question. B. Smith, Major Tarwater, Julia Lee, Megan Meeker, Rose Cosette, and Tess Schmidt. Where were the business school scenes shot in real life? Was it a real classroom on a campus? Were those real students or were they actors? Well, as Angela said, Ryan's business school and the scenes with Pam's art school were all shot at Cal State Northridge.
好的。我们有一个粉丝提问。B·史密斯、少校塔水、朱莉娅·李、梅根·米克尔、罗斯·柯赛特和苔丝·施密特。现实生活中商学院的场景是在哪里拍摄的？是校园里的真实教室吗？那些是真正的学生还是演员？正如安吉拉所说，瑞恩的商学院和帕姆艺术学校的场景都是在加州州立大学诺思里奇分校拍摄的。
How did you know it was Cal State Northridge, Ange? Because I listened to the DVD commentary. Oh. Yes. Well, Kent said all of the students in the classroom were hired extras. That we used a total of 122 background actors that day for the classroom scenes and the exterior campus scenes. He said that the business school and the exterior scenes were filmed on day one.
你怎么知道那是加州州立大学诺思里奇分校的，安琪？因为我听了DVD评论音轨。哦。是的。好吧，肯特说教室里的所有学生都是雇来的临时演员。那天我们在教室场景和校园外景场景中总共使用了122名背景演员。他说商学院和外景是在第一天拍摄的。
And on day two, we filmed the scenes for Pam's art show, which was held in the Cal State Northridge Design Center. One of the things I liked that they talked about in the DVD commentary was Brent said they asked all the people playing students if they would please bring their own personal laptop. Oh. And when I watched the scene, Jenna, I noticed that all the laptops were different. That is such a good detail.
第二天，我们拍摄了帕姆艺术展的场景，该艺术展在加州州立大学诺思里奇分校设计中心举行。我喜欢他们在DVD评论音轨中讨论的一件事是，布伦特说他们请所有扮演学生的带上他们自己的个人笔记本电脑。哦。当我观看这个场景时，珍娜，我注意到所有的笔记本电脑都不一样。这真是一个很好的细节。
Hmm. All right. Fast fact number three. Yeah. Nine days after this episode aired, Rainn Wilson hosted Saturday Night Live. Oh, you remember this? Yes. We were so excited for him.
嗯。好的。趣味事实三。是的。这一集播出九天后，雷恩·威尔逊主持了《周六夜现场》。哦，你还记得这个吗？是的。我们为他感到非常兴奋。
So we had to kind of move around our shooting schedule to make this happen for Rainn. And I just remember we were all so excited for him. And during his opening monologue, he did this bit. It's so funny where he says, oh, he's just so excited to be at Saturday Night Live because it's just way more exciting than shooting the office, which is basically just sitting at a desk on our fluorescent lights all day. He was like, on the set of SNL, there's like scaffolding and there's props and there's costumes and wigs, you know, it feels like a real show.
所以我们不得不调整我们的拍摄日程来为雷恩实现这一点。我只记得我们都为他感到非常兴奋。在他的开场独白中，他做了这个段子。太搞笑了，他说，哦，他只是很高兴能来到《周六夜现场》，因为这比拍摄《办公室》刺激多了，后者基本上就是整天坐在荧光灯下的办公桌前。他说，在SNL的片场，有脚手架、道具、服装和假发，你知道，感觉就像一个真正的节目。
And he's like, let me show you. Let me show you. And he takes the audience on like this backstage tour to show how exciting it is only to find the cast of Saturday Night Live kind of dressed up doing impersonations of all of our characters from the office. Yes. Well, Kristen Wiig is Pam and she's answering phones. Yes.
他说，让我展示一下。让我展示一下。他带领观众进行了一场后台参观，展示它是多么令人兴奋，结果发现《周六夜现场》的演员们盛装打扮，模仿着我们《办公室》里的所有角色。是的。好吧，克里斯汀·韦格扮演帕姆，她在接电话。是的。
And he's like, hey, Kristen. And she's like, SNL. Hi. Can I help you? Like she's like, I'm just answering phones and he's like, what are you doing? She's like, I do this all the time. I do a lot of things. He's like, don't you do anything else?
他说，嘿，克里斯汀。她说，SNL。嗨。我能帮你吗？就像她说的那样，我只是在接电话，他说，你在干什么？她说，我一直都在这么做。我做很多事情。他说，难道你什么都不做了吗？
And she's like, well, I also like to paint. And then she holds up a watercolor painting of 30 Rockefeller Center. That's where they film SNL. And that is a callback to this episode that had just aired of Pam's watercolor of Dunder Mifflin and I was freaking out excited when I saw it. Amy Poehler played me. Oh, it's so funny. And like had this like sort of like snarl and like kind of flirted with rain as Dwight.
她说，嗯，我也喜欢画画。然后她举起了一幅洛克菲勒中心30号的水彩画。那是他们拍摄SNL的地方。这是对刚刚播出的帕姆的邓德米夫林水彩画的回应，当我看到它时，我兴奋得抓狂。艾米·波勒扮演了我。哦，太搞笑了。而且还有一种像是怒视一样的表情，有点像调情一样对雷恩扮演的德怀特。
And if you remember, Jenna, Rashida was there that weekend and she's friends with a lot of the SNL cast members. So they were like, just hop in as Karen. So she did. He walks down the hall. Yeah. And they took all these pictures and Rashida emailed them to me. She was like, and look, it's Amy as you and I have all of these great pictures of them
如果你还记得的话，珍娜，蕾希达那个周末也在那里，她和许多SNL的演员是朋友。所以他们就说，快加入进来扮演凯伦吧。于是她照做了。他走过大厅。是的。他们拍了所有这些照片，蕾希达把它们发邮件给了我。她当时说，看，这是艾米扮演的你，我手里有他们那天在片场拍的所有这些精彩照片。
from the set that day. Amazing. Are you going to put those on the pod? On Office? Yes, I'll put one. I have a great one. I think I have a group shot. I'll put on the pod.
太棒了。你打算把这些发到播客上吗？在《办公室》上？是的，我会放一张。我有一张很棒的。我想我有一张合影。我会发到播客上的。
Well, listen to what Kristen Wiig did after that episode aired. What? So she and I shared a manager and we'd met a few times. We were both really struggling actresses at the same time. And kind of when I got on the office, she got on Saturday Night Live. So this was really thrilling to us. I get a package in the mail. It is the watercolor that she held up on the show.
好吧，听听克里斯汀·韦格在那一集播出后做了什么。什么？所以她和我共用一个经纪人，我们见过几次面。我们当时都是非常挣扎的女演员。基本上当我加入《办公室》时，她加入了《周六夜现场》。所以这对我们来说真的很激动人心。我收到一个包裹。正是她在节目中举起的那幅水彩画。
She signed the back of it. And then she wrote me the nicest note that was just like, I just know what it would mean to me if I were ever parodied on this television show. And I thought you might like to have a prop from the moment. So I asked if I could send this to you and they said yes. That is so lovely. Yeah, and I have it framed and it's in my family room. That is so great, Jenna.
她在背面签了名。然后她写给我最贴心的便条，大意是，我只是知道如果我曾经在这个电视节目中被模仿，对我来说意味着什么。我想你可能会想要那一刻的一个道具。所以我问我是否可以把它寄给你，他们说可以。太可爱了。是的，我把它裱起来了，放在我的家庭活动室里。太棒了，珍娜。
I never knew that. I've been in your family room a gazillion times. Yeah, it's up on the shelf with the Simpsons cartoon that Greg made of us. This is like my two treasured items. I'm going to look for it next time I'm at your house. She's the best, guys. That is so sweet. Well, listen, that's all I got.
我从来不知道这一点。我去过你家家庭活动室无数次了。是的，它放在架子上，旁边是格雷格为我们制作的《辛普森一家》卡通画。这就像我的两件珍宝。下次我去你家时我要找找看。她是最好的，伙计们。太甜了。好吧，听着，我就这些了。
I think we should go to a break and then we'll come back and talk all about business school with a bunch of great audio clips from Brent and a little special surprise from Kate Flannery. Yes. We'll see you. Okay, we are back and let's get into this episode. You guys, we start with Kevin arriving a little late to work and he says he almost died because his tire blew out. Michael doesn't care.
我想我们应该去休息一下，然后回来聊聊商学院，还有布伦特提供的一堆精彩音频片段以及凯特·弗兰纳里的一个小特别惊喜。好的。回头见。好的，我们回来了，让我们进入这一集。伙计们，我们从凯文稍微迟到上班开始，他说他差点死了，因为他的轮胎爆了。迈克尔根本不在乎。
He doesn't care. He just keeps saying, why is today a special day? And Jenna, when he said pop quiz, all I could think about was Keanu Reeves. Why? Because of speed. Oh, yeah. Pop quiz asshole. You have a hair trigger aimed at your head.
他不在乎。他只是不停地说，为什么今天是特殊的一天？珍娜，当他说突击测验时，我脑子里想的全是基努·里维斯。为什么？因为《生死时速》。哦，对了。突击测验，混蛋。你的脑门上正对着一把一触即发的枪。
What do you do? What do you do? When's the last time you watched this movie? Three days ago. Well, I see now why you made the connection. I know I'm really sad Michael didn't do a Keanu Reeves impression in this moment. Oh, well, that's a missed opportunity. I know that would have been full circle for me.
你怎么办？你怎么办？你上一次看这部电影是什么时候？三天前。好吧，我现在明白你为什么会有这种联系了。我知道我很遗憾迈克尔在这时没有模仿基努·里维斯。哦，好吧，这是一个错失的机会。我知道这对我和整个闭环来说都很有意义。
It would have made me very happy. But yeah, I remember shooting this scene and here's my problem. Whenever they would put Brian Baumgartner by reception to do anything Kevin, especially Kevin with like hurt feelings. I can't keep it together. I can't look at him when he is doing sad Kevin. I can't. So funny.
这会让我非常高兴。但是，是的，我记得拍摄这个场景，这是我的问题。每当他们把布赖恩·鲍姆加特纳安排在接待处做任何凯文做的事情，尤其是带着受伤感情的凯文。我就无法控制自己。当他扮演悲伤的凯文时，我不能看他。我不能。太搞笑了。
Well, Michael is excited because he gets to go to Ryan's business school and he's so happy. And we have a Ryan talking head where he's like, look, I get to go up a whole letter grade if I bring my boss in. I should. Yeah. I should do it. Right?
好吧，迈克尔很兴奋，因为他要去瑞恩的商学院了，他太高兴了。我们有一个瑞恩的访谈镜头，他说，听着，如果我把老板带去，我的等级可以提升一整级。我应该去。是的。我应该这么做。对吧？
No. No, you shouldn't, Ryan. Yeah. Well, we're going to see maybe no, you shouldn't, but Michael is just thrilled. We have a scene where Dwight is helping him pack. And this leads us to one of my favorite Dwight talking heads, which is a famous talking head. It is one of my favorite.
不。不，你不应该这么做，瑞恩。是的。好吧，我们可能会看到不，你不应该这么做，但迈克尔欣喜若狂。我们有一个德怀特帮他收拾行李的场景。这让我们想到了我最喜欢的德怀特访谈镜头之一，这是一个著名的访谈镜头。这是我最喜欢的之一。
My kids love this talking head so much, Jenna. Michael's asking him, what is the best advice I ever gave you? And Dwight's like, the best advice you ever gave me, Michael, is don't be an idiot. It changed my life and then it cuts to this famous amazing talking head where Dwight looks at Cameron says, whenever I'm about to do something, I think, would an idiot do that? And if they would, I do not do that thing. I love it. I just wrote out a birthday card to a young woman who was turning 21 and I put this in
我的孩子们非常喜欢这个访谈镜头，珍娜。迈克尔问他，我给过你的最好建议是什么？德怀特说，迈克尔，你给过我最好的建议就是别当个傻瓜。它改变了我的生活，接着镜头切到了这个著名的惊人访谈镜头，德怀特看着镜头说，每当我准备做什么事时，我都会想，一个傻瓜会这么做吗？如果会，我就不做那件事。我太喜欢了。我刚给一个即将21岁的年轻女性写了一张生日卡片，我把这个写进去了
her card. I said, listen, that's brilliant as you, as you move on to this next phase of adulthood. Remember these wise words from Dwight's route. Yes. That is so good. So I use this all the time. So then Michael's in the car with Ryan and he's like, man, do you think people are going to throw their hats in the air after my speech, you know, because they do that sometimes and
她的卡片。我说，听着，这太棒了，当你，当你迈入成年期的下一个阶段时。记住德怀特·鲁特这些明智的话。是的。太棒了。所以我经常用这个。所以迈克尔和瑞恩坐在车里，他说，天啊，你觉得人们会在我的演讲之后把帽子扔向空中吗，你知道的，因为他们在毕业典礼上有时会那样做，
graduations or at Naval academies and Ryan's like, yeah, this is, I don't, this is just, it's not that. It's not that occasion. I loved this actual line from Ryan. Jenna made me laugh out loud because he says, you understand, no one is graduating and you've got to know Ryan is now crapping in his pants because he's like, he has a line prepared if they throw their hats. And this is the line.
或者在海军学校，瑞恩说，是的，这个，我不知道，这不是那个。这不是那种场合。我真的很喜欢瑞恩的这句台词。珍娜让我哈哈大笑，因为他说，你要明白，没有人毕业，而且你得知道瑞恩现在吓得屁滚尿流，因为他就像，他准备好了一句台词，以防他们扔帽子。这就是台词。
May your hats fly as high as your dreams. And I have seen people put that on their graduation hats for graduations. I have too. So now we go back to the office and this is when we learn about Pam's art show because Roy says he's really excited. We have back to back really awkward Pam and Jim talking heads. Yeah. Pam's like, I'm happy to be with Roy.
愿你们的帽子飞得和你们的梦想一样高。我见过人们把它贴在毕业帽上参加毕业典礼。我也见过。所以现在我们回到办公室，这时我们知道了帕姆的艺术展，因为罗伊说他真的很兴奋。我们有了连续两个非常尴尬的帕姆和吉姆的访谈镜头。是的。帕姆说，我很高兴能和罗伊在一起。
And then Jim's like, yeah, Pam's with Roy. I'm Kevin moving on. And I'm just like, okay, guys, I think he's with Karen. Who would I say? Kevin. No, I didn't. You did. And everyone listening right now just heard you say, oh no, maybe I should take a sip
然后吉姆说，是的，帕姆和罗伊在一起。我是凯文，继续前进。我当时就想，好吧，伙计们，我想他和凯文在一起。我刚才说了谁？凯文。不，我没有。你说了。现在正在听的每个人都听到你说了，哦，不，也许我应该喝一口
of my tea. Maybe I need more caffeine this morning. Wake yourself up. You were up late last night. I was lady. I was. I know because I woke up to a string of messages from you that were sent at like 1230 in the morning.
我的茶。也许我今天早上需要更多的咖啡因。让自己清醒点。你昨晚睡得很晚。是的，女士。我是。我知道，因为我醒来时看到你发来的一连串信息，大约是半夜12点半发送的。
I was like, thank you. Like, what is it? Does it alert you or something? I have my alert. No, no. It was when I woke up. I woke up and looked at my phone and I was like, wow, because I woke up really early this morning and I was shocked to see all these messages from you.
我当时想，谢谢。就像，这是什么？它会提醒你什么的吗？我有提醒。不，不。那是我醒来的时候。我醒来看了看手机，然后我想，哇，因为我今天早上醒得很早，看到你发来的所有这些信息，我感到很震惊。
I was like, wow, Angela's a real early bird today too. Look at us. And I was like, no, they were from late last night. Yeah, they were from really late last night. I wasn't up being an idiot. I was, I was working. Jenna and I, you know, we have some other stuff. I didn't say you were up being an idiot.
我想，哇，安吉拉今天也是个地道的早起鸟。看看我们。我说，不，那是昨晚很晚发来的。是的，那是昨晚真的很晚发来的。我不是在熬夜当傻瓜。我在工作。珍娜和我，你知道的，我们还有其他事情。我没说你熬夜当傻瓜。
No, I know. I'm telling the 21 year olds out there. Jenna and I have some other stuff guys that were hatching up and I was working on one of them. And we have something brewing. I was inspired late last night. Okay. I like that.
不，我知道。我在告诉外面那些21岁的人。珍娜和我有一些其他的事情，伙计们，我们在密谋，我正在做其中一件。我们正在酝酿着什么。我昨晚很晚受到启发。好吧。我喜欢这样。
I've had a cup of tea. I'm waking myself up. I'm not going to call Karen, Kevin. So now Pam tells Kelly about her art show, Mindy's performance, where she feigns interest and acts like she's going to come is just fricking amazing. It's perfect. Yeah. It's all of us when we've been invited to something that we know we're not going to
我喝了一杯茶。我正在让自己清醒。我不会把凯文叫成凯伦的。现在帕姆把她的艺术展告诉了凯莉，敏迪的表演，她假装感兴趣并表现得好像她会来，简直是太棒了。太完美了。是的。这就是我们所有人被邀请参加某些我们知道自己不会去的事情时的样子，
go to, but we're saying we're going to go to it. Yeah. Oh, I would. Yes. Yes. Oh, yes. I will absolutely be there. Yes.
但我们嘴上说我们会去。是的。哦，我会的。是的。哦，是的。我绝对会去的。是的。
Uh-huh. I can't wait. All right. So now Michael arrives on campus. He is so excited. There's just all of these memories coming back to him that he's having that might have occurred if he had ever attended college. That made me sad, by the way.
嗯哼。我等不及了。好了。现在迈克尔到达了校园。他太兴奋了。所有这些回忆都涌上心头，如果他曾经上过大学的话，这些可能就已经发生了。顺便说一句，这让我很难过。
It made me sad too. I mean, Michael would have loved college. I think Michael would have been like an RA in the dorm, you know? 100%. And he probably would have been like a life for RA. They probably would have been like, you can leave now. And he's like, no, we got another batch of students coming in and they're like, you're not a student anymore.
这也让我很难过。我是说，迈克尔本会喜欢大学的。我觉得迈克尔本会成为宿舍里的宿舍助理（RA），你知道的？百分之百。他可能还会成为终身RA。他们可能会说，你现在可以走了。他说，不，我们还有另一批学生要来，而他们会说，你不再是学生了。
Yeah. Yeah, that's true. It's true. Well, uh, we had a fan comment from Amber Morris. Okay. You know that moment when Michael runs up and tries to join the Frisbee game? Yeah. She says, fun, fast fact.
是的。是的，那是真的。确实如此。好吧，嗯，我们收到了安伯·莫里斯的粉丝评论。好的。你知道迈克尔跑过去试图加入飞盘游戏的那个时刻吗？是的。她说，一个有趣的趣味事实。
A friend of mine, Nathan Blank, played the Frisbee student at Ryan's school. Michael ran up and stole a Frisbee and threw it and Nathan's line was something like, dude. And he has had nothing but wonderful things to say about his filming day and working with Steve and BJ. Aw, I love that. Yeah. That is very sweet. That scene made me laugh really hard because everything about how Steve approached that
我的一个朋友，内森·布兰克，在瑞恩的学校里扮演了玩飞盘的学生。迈克尔跑过去抢了一个飞盘并把它扔了出去，内森的台词大概是，老兄。对于他的拍摄日以及与史蒂夫和BJ的合作，他只有赞美之词。啊，我喜欢这个。是的。这非常甜蜜。那个场景让我笑得很大声，因为史蒂夫处理那个
Frisbee was wrong. No one should ever grab a Frisbee and throw it that way. And it just was so perfect. Well now we're going to go back to the office, Angela, because now that other card that Brent talked about, the one that says bad in office is about to go into play. We're in the office. Dwight sees some kind of animal feces. He's on the case.
飞盘的方式全都不对。任何人都不应该抓起一个飞盘然后用那种方式扔出去。这实在是太完美了。现在我们要回到办公室了，安吉拉，因为布伦特谈到的另一张卡片，写着“办公室里有蝙蝠”的那张，马上就要派上用场了。我们在办公室里。德怀特看到了一些动物粪便。他在处理这个案子。
He's like, oh, there's a bird in the rafters, guys, but it's not a bird. It's a bat. No. And everyone freaks out. Everyone except Jim and Creed. Oh yeah, Creed is ready. Angela stops, drops, and rolls. Yeah.
他说，哦，天花板上有只鸟，伙计们，但那不是鸟。是只蝙蝠。不。每个人都吓坏了。除了吉姆和克里德，所有人都在惊慌。哦，是的，克里德已经准备好了。安吉拉倒地、趴下、打滚。是的。
Stanley leaves. Eventually Dwight is able to lock the bat in the conference room after a bunch of mayhem. Fan question from Leona Woldridge, Ruth Rodriguez, Heather Flynn, and Abby Moll. At approximately five minutes, Angela drops and rolls while the bat flies around. Then you barely hear her voice in the background, either talking to herself or praying. Do you know what you're saying? I do. I remember Joss saying to me, all right, Angela would totally freak out and, you know, we
斯坦利离开了。最终，在一阵混乱之后，德怀特能够把蝙蝠锁在会议室里。莱娜·沃尔德里奇、露丝·罗德里格斯、希瑟·弗林和艾比·莫尔的粉丝提问。在大约五分钟时，安吉拉在蝙蝠飞来飞去时倒地并打滚。然后你隐约听到她在背景里的声音，要么是在自言自语，要么是在祈祷。你知道你在说什么吗？我知道。我记得乔斯对我说，好吧，安吉拉会彻底吓坏的，你知道，我们
talked about what did that look like and what I dropped to the ground. And I came up with this dropping to the ground and rolling. That's my memory, Jenna, that I dropped to the ground and I decided to roll. And Joss really liked that. And then I just laid face down on the carpet and I improvised this. And I said something like, God, this is Angela Martin, please don't let that stupid thing come anywhere near me. And I just sort of mumbled these prayers.
讨论过那会是什么样子以及我该如何倒地。我想出了倒地和打滚这一招。我的记忆是，珍娜，我倒在地上，我决定打滚。乔斯真的很喜欢那样。然后我只是面朝下趴在地毯上，我即兴发挥了这段。我说了一些类似的话，上帝，我是安吉拉·马丁，请不要让那个愚蠢的东西靠近我。我就这样嘟囔着这些祈祷。
I love it. When I was a child and I would pray, I would lead with, God, this is Jenna Fisher. I would lead with an introduction. Same. 100%. Yeah. I would do it. I need God to know, like, I need him to like key in to who are these prayers for as I'm
我喜欢。当我还是个孩子的时候，当我祈祷时，我会以“上帝，我是珍娜·费舍”开头。我会以自我介绍开头。一样。百分之百。是的。我会这么做。我需要上帝知道，就像，我需要他弄清楚这些祈祷是为谁准备的，当我在
receiving these prayers. Who are they coming from? So I thought, well, I'll lead with my name. I used to say, Lord God, this is Angela Kinsey. I'm in my bedroom. I am on a street called Kavling in Jakarta, Indonesia. That is in the Southern Hemisphere. It's a group of islands.
接受这些祈祷时。它们来自哪里？所以我想，好吧，我会以我的名字开头。我曾经说过，主啊，我是安吉拉·金斯利。我在我的卧室里。我在印度尼西亚雅加达一条叫卡夫林的街道上。那在南半球。那是一群岛屿。
I'm just below the equator. Like, I needed him to know where I was. That was some serious location honing right there. Yeah. You were like, the coordinates are 75 degrees latitude. I'm in my bedroom. It's down the hall on the right. It's across from the bathroom.
我在赤道正下方。就像，我需要他知道我在哪里。那真是一种严肃的定位导航。是的。你就像，坐标是北纬75度。我在我的卧室里。它在走廊右手边。它正对着浴室。
Oh my gosh. I did not get that specific, but I applaud that. Thank you. Then we had more fan questions about this scene. From Rosalie W., Tanner W., Mia F., and Jacob W., was the bat that got trapped in the office a real bat. Kentopedia says, yes, we used a real bat for three scenes. The scene where Dwight stands on Pam's reception desk to look inside the ceiling, a few shots
噢，天哪。我没有那么具体，但我为之鼓掌。谢谢。然后我们关于这个场景有更多的粉丝提问。来自罗莎莉·W、坦纳·W、米娅·F和雅各布·W，被困在办公室里的蝙蝠是真蝙蝠吗？肯特百科说，是的，我们在三个场景中使用了真蝙蝠。德怀特站在帕姆的接待桌上查看天花板内部的场景，还有几个镜头
of the bat on the ceiling in the conference room, and for that shot of the bat on the ceiling in the kitchen. Kent hired two bat wranglers to provide us with the bat, Chad Dunn and John Baldwin. They put Chad up in the ceiling to hold the bat for that scene where Dwight peers in, the one we were just talking about. The rest of the time when we see the bat flying around, that was all CGI. Kent said he hired Mitch Suskin as our visual effects supervisor. He was great, did a terrific job, and they worked with several production houses to animate
展示会议室天花板上的蝙蝠，以及厨房天花板上蝙蝠的那个镜头。肯特雇用了两位蝙蝠驯兽师为我们提供蝙蝠，查德·邓恩和约翰·鲍德温。他们把查德放到天花板里为那个德怀特窥视的场景拿着蝙蝠，就是我们刚才讨论的那个。其余我们看到蝙蝠飞来飞去的镜头，全都是CGI。肯特说他聘请了米奇·萨斯金担任我们的视觉特效总监。他很棒，做得非常出色，他们与几家制作公司合作制作了动画
the bat. And then there was a third kind of bat that we used, which we will talk about later in the scene with Kate. And it was a mechanical bat. Yes. So three different bats. Three different bats. I have a tiny bit of bat trivia.
蝙蝠。然后还有我们使用的第三种蝙蝠，我们稍后会在凯特的场景中讨论。它是一只机械蝙蝠。是的。所以是三种不同的蝙蝠。三种不同的蝙蝠。我有一点点关于蝙蝠的冷知识。
Oh! Lay it on me. Okay. Here's my little bit of bat trivia from this episode. In the DVD commentary, Rain says he named the bat, that he was talking to the bat wrangler, and Rain said, what's his name? And the bat wrangler was like, oh, we've never given him a name. And Rain was like, what?
哦！说来听听。好吧。这是我从这一集中收集的一点蝙蝠冷知识。在DVD评论音轨中，雷恩说他给蝙蝠取了名字，他当时正在跟蝙蝠驯兽师说话，雷恩说，它叫什么名字？蝙蝠驯兽师说，哦，我们从来没给它取过名字。雷恩说，什么？
I'm going to name him. And so Rain named the bat, Gary. It's Gary. Oh. Gary the bat, and we called him Gary all week. Well, good job, Gary. Yeah. And now my question is, Rain, if you ever listen to this, is that Michael Gary Scott?
我要给它取个名字。于是雷恩给蝙蝠取名叫加里。是加里。哦。加里这只蝙蝠，我们整整一周都叫它加里。好吧，干得好，加里。是的。现在我的问题是，雷恩，如果你曾经听过这个，那是迈克尔·加里·斯科特吗？
Oh. Oh. Oh. Or is it just Gary? Gary the bat. Well, I remember shooting this scene, Angela, because they laid out for us this very elaborate trail of how the bat would fly so that we could all react to it, because we're reacting to nothing.
哦。哦。哦。还是只是加里？加里这只蝙蝠。好吧，我记得拍摄这个场景，安吉拉，因为他们为我们详细规划了蝙蝠飞行的路线，这样我们才能对它做出反应，因为我们是在对着空气做出反应。
Mm-hmm. Nothing is flying through the ceiling. Right. And so it was really choreographed, like, bat is here, bat is there, bat swoops here, bat goes into conference room. And I, it looks so real. Yeah. So, yeah, guys, we are screaming at and reacting to nothing flying through the office.
嗯哼。没有什么东西在天花板上飞。对吧。所以这真的是经过精心编排的，就像，蝙蝠在这里，蝙蝠在那里，蝙蝠从这里俯冲下来，蝙蝠飞进会议室。而我，它看起来太真实了。所以，是的，伙计们，我们是在对着办公室里飞来飞去的空气尖叫和做出反应。
Yeah. We're not freaking out the bat. We're not screaming at him. I have a few background catches from the scene. Lay them on me. Three minutes, 54 seconds. Pam is sketching a tape dispenser. Yeah.
是的。我们没有吓唬蝙蝠。我们不是在对它尖叫。我从这个场景中捕捉到了几个背景细节。说来听听。3分54秒。帕姆在素描一个胶带座。是的。
We don't see it, though, at the art show. Well, she doesn't have time to watercolor that before the art show. Well, I didn't know. This is just something she's doing on the side. Well, that's what I was going to ask, is she last minute trying to hustle up some more art for her wall? No, she just has a light work day and she's sketching at her desk. At four minutes, 26 seconds, Rain's butt is right in your face.
不过我们在艺术展上没看到它。嗯，她在艺术展之前没有时间画这个水彩画。嗯，我不知道。这只是她在旁边做的事。嗯，这就是我要问的，她是在最后一分钟赶着为她的墙壁凑集更多的艺术品吗？不，她只是今天工作轻松，在座位上画素描。在4分26秒，雷恩的屁股直接怼在你脸上了。
Super right in my face. Super right in your face. You're like, Dwight, what are you doing? His butt is right in your face. Yeah. Rain thought that was very funny. I'm sure he did. I'm not going to give you a deep dive on bats.
超级怼在我脸上。超级怼在我脸上。你就像，德怀特，你在干什么？他的屁股直接怼在你脸上了。是的。雷恩觉得那非常搞笑。我确信他觉得。我不会给你深入探讨蝙蝠的。
I am shocked. It's me and my kids listen to this amazing podcast, it's four families and kids called Smash Boom Best. What they do is they have two people debate two different things and then a kid decides which one is better. Oh, cute. It's so cute. They had one called Bats versus Owls.
我很震惊。我和我的孩子们在听这个精彩的播客，它是由四个家庭和孩子组成的，叫做《决战爆米花》（Smash Boom Best）。他们所做的是让两个人辩论两件不同的事情，然后由一个孩子决定哪一个更好。哦，可爱。太可爱了。他们有一个主题叫蝙蝠对猫头鹰。
If you want to learn some really cool stuff about bats and owls, I recommend this podcast because we loved it. They eat a ton of mosquitoes, guys, especially in Texas. There's this huge swarm of bats that's responsible for really controlling the mosquito population. And their feces can be used as energy. Uh-oh. I maybe am telling you some bad facts. Now you're telling us bad facts.
如果你想了解一些关于蝙蝠和猫头鹰的超级酷的知识，我推荐这个播客，因为我们非常喜欢它。它们吃大量的蚊子，伙计们，尤其是在德克萨斯州。这里有一大群蝙蝠，它们真正负责控制蚊子种群。它们的粪便可以用来作为能源。哦，不。我可能在告诉你一些糟糕的事实。现在你开始告诉我们糟糕的事实了。
Toby has a fantastic talking head during all this chaos and he's like, you know, the simple solution would just be to open a window, but none of our windows open. That's a little creepy. It really is. Well, Angela, then you have a talking head where you say, I can't even say it. This is one of my most quoted lines to me. You know, like when you meet fans of the show and they quote a line to you, this is one of the lines.
托比在所有这些混乱中有一个极好的访谈镜头，他说，你知道的，最简单的解决办法就是打开一扇窗户，但我们的窗户都打不开。这有点诡异。确实如此。好吧，安吉拉，然后你有一个访谈镜头，你说，我简直说不出口。这是我最常被人引用的台词之一。你知道的，就像当你遇到节目的粉丝，他们对你引用一句台词时，这就是其中一句。
Strangers would come up to me and be like, poop is raining from the ceilings. Poop. It's so good. Angela, we had a fan question from Jackie K. How many takes did it require for Angela to get the poop is raining from the ceiling talking head? We did a few because we, we were playing around with what type of distress was this for Angela? Was she angry or terrified, scared, annoyed? So we did a few and the one they picked was where I'm actually concerned and scared.
陌生人会走到我面前说，粪便正从天花板上雨点般落下。粪便。太棒了。安吉拉，我们收到了杰基·K的粉丝提问。安吉拉拍了多少条才完成了“粪便正从天花板上雨点般落下”的访谈镜头？我们拍了好几条，因为我们在尝试，对安吉拉来说这是一种什么样的痛苦？她是生气还是惊恐、害怕、恼火？所以我们拍了几条，他们选中的那一条是我实际上表现出关心和害怕的。
And I have my rain bonnet on. I was going to say the rain bonnet is everything, everything Angela, my grandmother had one of those. Yes. My grandmother got her hair done once a week, same, and it would be the same hairdo. It was set for the whole week. Yeah. That's what the ladies used to do.
我戴着雨帽。我正要说那顶雨帽简直是一切，安吉拉的一切，我外祖母就有一顶那样的。是的。我外祖母一周做一次头发，也是一样，发型永远都一样。整个星期都是那个发型。是的。那是老一辈女士们过去常常做的。
They used to have their weekly appointment. They'd get their hair washed and set and then just teased and sprayed. Yeah. And then my grandma had this little rain bonnet folded up in her purse. And if there was even a sprinkle, she would throw that thing on. Yes. Same with my grandmother. I had so many memories of her putting it on, going to church, because there was just maybe
她们过去常常每周去一次美发沙龙。她们洗头、定型，然后吹风、喷发胶。是的。然后我奶奶的钱包里折叠着这顶小雨帽。哪怕有一点点小雨，她也会把那东西戴上。是的，我外祖母也是。我有太多她戴着它去教堂的回忆，因为可能只是
a tiny, tiny bit of mist. I was just tickled by this scene because it made me think of my grandmother. And I love that Angela Martin keeps one on hand. She has a rain bonnet ready to go. When I saw it, I thought we need to bring back this rain bonnet. I looked online. There's a lot you can buy now and you know I love a good pun. There is a company that makes one and they call it the hairbrella.
一点点毛毛雨。这个场景让我觉得很有趣，因为它让我想起了我的外祖母。我喜欢安吉拉·马丁随身携带一顶。她准备好了一顶雨帽。当我看到它时，我想我们需要把这顶雨帽带回时尚界。我在网上查过。现在有很多你可以买的，而且你知道我喜欢双关语。有一家公司生产这种帽子，他们把它叫做“头发伞”（hairbrella）。
I want a hairbrella. Well, Jim calls animal control and they say they're going to be there by six o'clock, but Dwight finds this unacceptable. Yeah. But this is when Jim starts his prank on Dwight. He's distracted by this bite on his neck and he's just feeling like really tingly and strangely powerful. Huh.
我想要一把头发伞。好吧，吉姆打电话给动物管制中心，他们说他们六点钟前会到，但德怀特觉得这不可接受。是的。但这就是吉姆开始对德怀特恶作剧的时候。他的脖子被咬了一下，分了心，他觉得麻酥酥的，而且有一种奇怪的强大力量。哼。
I can't explain it. That's all he has to do and Dwight fills in all the blanks. Well, now back at the business school, Michael is in like a sound booth watching Ryan sort of give an introduction is what he thinks, right? But Ryan is basically telling the classroom that Dunder Mifflin can't compete with the bigger chains. He thinks this whole business is going to be obsolete in like five years. And in fact, he thinks the management isn't flexible and able to adapt.
我无法解释。他只需要做这些，德怀特就会脑补所有的空白。好吧，现在回到商学院，迈克尔在一个录音棚里看着瑞恩做自我介绍，他以为是这样，对吧？但瑞恩基本上是在对全班说邓德米夫林无法与大型连锁店竞争。他认为整个业务在五年左右就会过时。事实上，他认为管理层不够灵活，无法适应。
And you know what I wrote? What? Ryan, how dare you? You know what this means to Michael. How dare you set him up like that? Look at that. If that conversation was going to come out in the classroom on its own, fine. But Ryan could have set him up differently.
你知道我写了什么吗？什么？瑞恩，你怎么敢？你知道这对迈克尔意味着什么吗？你怎么能这样给他挖坑？瞧瞧这个。如果这种对话本来就会在课堂上自然而然地出现，那也就算了。但瑞恩本可以用不同的方式铺垫。
He could have said, you know what guys, Dunder Mifflin is a small company. It has a harder time competing, but you know what? Management really believes in it. They really believe in like a one-on-one personal connection. And my boss is someone is he's sort of part of a dying breed of a traditional salesman. He's being a total punk in this moment. I think so. Well, then when Michael takes the stage thinking he's been introduced in a totally different,
他本可以说，你知道吗，伙计们，邓德米夫林是一家小公司。它更难竞争，但你知道吗？管理层真的很相信它。他们真的很相信一对一的个人联系。我的老板是一个，他有点像传统推销员中濒危物种的一部分。他此刻完全像个小流氓。我也这么觉得。好吧，然后当迈克尔登上讲台，以为自己受到了完全不同、
more flattering way, he enters with his own musical fanfare that he has brought with him. He shows up with his boom box. Yeah. He's playing like classical music. That's a bold move. No matter how Ryan set you up, even if Ryan had painted you in an amazing light, to walk in with your boom box playing, your intro song is really, is a really bold move. Knowing everything we know about Michael, it's surprising that he didn't show up dressed
更具奉承意味的介绍时，他伴随着自己带来的音乐狂欢入场了。他带着他的音响出场了。是的。他在播放古典音乐。这真是个大胆的举动。无论瑞恩是怎么给你铺垫的，即使瑞恩把你描绘成一个极其光辉的形象，带着你的音响播放入场曲走进来，也真的是一个非常大胆的举动。了解我们所知道的关于迈克尔的一切，令人惊讶的是，他没有穿成某个角色来激励学生，而是以他自己的身份来的。
as a character to inspire the students, but he has come as himself. But he does bring props. Oh, does he ever? Well, he starts by tearing up someone's book as a way of inspiring them. And then he moves into his candy bar runner pun. Then he lets the classroom know there are four kinds of businesses. Number one, tourism, number two, food service, number three, railroads, number four, sales, number five, hospital and manufacturing, and then also air travel.
但他确实带了道具。哦，他带了吗？好吧，他首先撕毁了某个人的书来激励他们。然后他谈到他的巧克力棒推销员双关语。接着他让全班知道有四种类型的企业。第一种是旅游业，第二种是餐饮服务，第三种是铁路，第四种是销售，第五种是医院和制造业，还有航空旅行。
My favorite is hospital slash manufacturing. I know. So then he moves into his candy bar puns. Oh, yeah. So good. So good. Do you know who wrote this whole scene? Who?
我最喜欢的是医院杠制造业。我知道。然后他转到了他的巧克力棒双关语。哦，太棒了。太棒了。你知道是谁写了整个场景吗？谁？
Jen Salada. Oh, that makes so much sense. It's so great, isn't it? Well, we had a lot of people write in. Sammy Sales, Allie Stechling, Lily McGrath all asked, how much of Michael's speech to Ryan's business class was improvised? Guys, basically none of it. It was almost like I went to the script.
珍·萨拉达。哦，这就说得通了。太棒了，不是吗？好吧，我们有很多人写信来。萨米·萨尔斯、阿莉·斯特克林、莉莉·麦格拉思都问过，迈克尔对瑞恩商学院演讲的有多少是即兴发挥的？伙计们，基本上没有。几乎就像我是照着剧本来的。
It's basically all scripted. What you see there in the episode, scripted. Yeah. You know, we didn't get to be there, Jenna, to be in that classroom. It looked like so much fun. So we asked Brent Forrester, what was it like to shoot those scenes with Michael and the students? And here's what he had to say.
基本上全都是剧本里的。你在那一集中看到的，全是剧本。你知道，我们当时没能在那里，珍娜，没能进那个教室。看起来太有趣了。所以我们问布伦特·福雷斯特，和史蒂夫·卡瑞尔以及那些坐在阶梯教室里的孩子们一起拍摄那些场景是什么感觉？以下是他的看法。
Following the business school scenes with Steve Carell in that lecture hall full of kids was really unforgettable. And I kind of suspected that it was going to go great because I knew that Steve had come from this live performance tradition with Second City, and that he really thrives on that live audience connection. And here was a chance for him to perform both in front of a camera and in front of a live audience of kids who at this time were all fans of the office. We were in season three at this point.
跟随史蒂夫·卡瑞尔在那个坐满孩子的阶梯教室里拍摄商学院的场景真的是令人难忘。我有点预感这会非常棒，因为我知道史蒂夫来自第二城剧团（Second City）的现场表演传统，并且他在那种现场观众的互动中茁壮成长。而这对他来说是一个机会，既能在镜头前表演，也能在一群在这个时候都是《办公室》粉丝的现场孩子面前表演。我们当时正处于第三季。
What I remember is the way these takes would go. Steve would perform the scene, and then the kids in the audience would have to pretend that they were very unimpressed by his lecture, and so they would sit there in silence. And then the assistant director would call cut, and then the whole group of kids would just burst out into laughter that they'd been repressing through the whole scene. So over and over again, it was Steve performs, silence, cut, huge laugh. Then in the final take of the final scene, Steve performs, there's silence, the AD says cut, that's a wrap for Steve.
我记得这些拍摄是如何进行的。史蒂夫会表演这个场景，然后观众席上的孩子们必须假装对他的讲课非常无动于衷，所以他们会静静地坐在那里。然后助理导演会喊停，接着所有的孩子们就会爆发出他们在整个场景中一直压抑的笑声。所以一遍又一遍，过程是史蒂夫表演，安静，停，爆笑。然后是在最后一个场景的最后一次拍摄中，史蒂夫表演，全场安静，副导演喊停，史蒂夫的戏份杀青了。
The audience of kids burst into laughter, they stand up, and they give him this ovation that went on forever. I was standing next to Steve at the time, and I saw the tears come to his eyes. It was so beautiful, one of the highlights for sure of my time on the office. Oh my gosh, I wish I could have been there. I bet it felt so magical to those kids, you know. And to Steve too, he basically had this whole audience just for himself. And kind of what Brent was talking about, which is that Steve started in live performance.
现场的孩子们爆发出笑声，他们站起来，为他送上了持久不息的起立鼓掌。我当时正站在史蒂夫旁边，我看到眼泪夺眶而出。太美妙了，绝对是我在《办公室》工作的亮点之一。噢，天哪，我真希望当时能在场。我打赌对那些孩子们来说这一定感觉太神奇了。对史蒂夫也是如此，他基本上完全拥有了这群观众。这有点像布伦特所说的，史蒂夫是以现场表演起家的。
And I did too with theater, Angela, and it was a big adjustment to be sort of acting into a void, which is the camera. You don't get to see your jokes land. You don't get to hear people in their living rooms at home, you know, moving through your performance with you like you do in a theater situation. So it's always fun to get to perform for a live audience. Always, always. That was my whole, you know, every week doing an improv show, and it is a real energy to
我也是通过戏剧起家的，安吉拉，这需要做出很大的调整，去向一个虚空演戏，也就是摄像机。你看不到你的笑话有没有抖响。你听不到人们在他们自己家的客厅里，你知道的，像在剧场里那样与你的表演产生共鸣。所以能够为现场观众表演总是很有趣。总是如此，总是如此。那就是我的全部，你知道，每周做一场即兴表演，拥有一个这样的房间，与你同在，与你产生当下共鸣的那种能量，总是会让我的皮肤感到微微发麻。
have a room like that with you, and in the moment with you, it just always kind of makes my skin tingle. All right. So should we go check in at Dunder Mifflin now, because Dwight is making a trap for the bat using a box and some glue, so we're bad, terrible. And in the background, Jim and Karen are continuing this prank. Yeah. Karen is doing it, not Pam.
好了。所以我们现在要去邓德米夫林视察一下吗，因为德怀特正在用一个盒子和一些胶水为蝙蝠做一个陷阱，所以我们很糟糕，太糟糕了。在背景中，吉姆和凯伦正在继续这个恶作剧。是的。是凯伦在做，而不是帕姆。
I noticed. And I don't, I mean, I don't want to be. Oh, here it comes. I mean, was Pam better at pranking? You said it. I mean, yes. I feel like Jim and Karen's prank is a little presentational and a little on the nose. And I think that when Pam pranks Dwight with Jim, it's more subtle and creative.
我注意到了。而且我不想，我是说，我不想。哦，它来了。我是说，帕姆在恶作剧方面更好吗？你说了。我是说，是的。我觉得吉姆和凯伦的恶作剧有点表现主义，而且有点过于直白了。我觉得当帕姆和吉姆一起捉弄德怀特时，它更微妙、更有创意。
I don't know. Yeah. Well, you know, it's really hard to have the finesse of like drinking your water by the water cooler and, you know, covering up whatever Jim is doing by drinking a little cup of water and looking around. I mean, that is hard. That is, that doesn't come natural. I knew you were going to bring that up because it's the one time that Pam is terrible at
我不知道。是的，你知道的，要有那种在饮水机旁喝水然后，你知道的，通过喝一小杯水和四处张望来掩饰吉姆在做什么的技巧，真的是很难。我的意思是，那很难，那不是自然而然就能做出来的。我知道你会提起这个，因为那是帕姆唯一一次恶作剧搞砸。这让我笑了。但它确实让我笑了。但我很抱歉。她的其他恶作剧非常棒。
pranking. It makes me laugh. But it makes me laugh. But I'm sorry. Her other pranks are very good. But yes, so they have this whole bit where like Jim can't pick up her piece of bread. It's white hot. Because it's garlic bread and it's burning his hands and she's like, this is ice cold.
但是，是的，他们有这个整段戏，吉姆拿不起她的一片面包。烫得要命。因为那是大蒜面包，烫伤了他的手，而她说，这冰凉刺骨。然后我们进入，我的意思是，休息室里又一次出现了一点心碎的时刻，是托比。但那是托比。哦，是的。
And then we go into, I mean, it's a little bit of heartbreak in the break room again with Toby. But it's Toby. Oh yeah. It's Toby has some heartbreak. I mean, you guys, Toby is in love with Pam and here is his opportunity to see her outside of work and maybe dazzle her somehow with his knowledge of art and support her. And it's the same evening of his daughter's play and he's devastated and he's even trying
托比心碎了。我的意思是，伙计们，托比爱上了帕姆，这是他看到她工作之外的一面的机会，也许可以用他的艺术知识以某种方式迷住她并支持她。而这正好是他女儿话剧上演的同一天，他崩溃了，他甚至在试图
to think of a way to get out of going to see his child's play. I know. He's like, it's just, we need to support local art and what they're doing is not art. Let's be honest. Pam's like, Pam's like, you should go see your child's play. Yes. Yes. Oh.
想办法逃掉去看他孩子的戏剧。我知道。他说，这只是，我们需要支持本地艺术，而他们做的根本算不上艺术。老实说。帕姆说，帕姆说，你应该去看看你孩子的戏剧。是的。是的。哦。
Oh. Well, lady, while this is going on, back at the school, they're starting to get into the Q&A part, right? And the students are starting to ask Michael questions. Things are kind of falling apart. There's a moment, Jenna, I love so much. I love it when Michael says, real business is done on paper. Write that down and they all type.
哦。好吧，女士，当这一切正在发生时，回到学校，他们开始进入问答环节了，对吧？学生们开始问迈克尔问题。事情开始分崩离析了。有一个时刻，珍娜，我太喜欢了。我喜欢迈克尔说，真正的生意是用纸完成的。把它记下来，然后他们全都在打字。
Yeah. It's just a sound of keyboards. Yes. That's a very fun joke in the script too. Like it says, the students all get out their computers and begin typing. It's so good. So the students start asking him, how would you keep a client from leaving Dunder Mifflin for a nationwide chain?
是的。那只是一片键盘敲击声。是的。剧本里这也是一个非常有趣的笑话。就像上面写着，学生们都掏出电脑开始打字。太棒了。所以学生们开始问他，你将如何阻止客户为了全国性连锁店而离开邓德米夫林？
And Michael's like, I don't need to persuade them to come back. They'll just come back eventually when they realize what a debacle it is to go to anyone else. And then the student's like, well, has anyone ever come back? And Michael's like, I don't want them back because they're stupid. Michael is starting to take this personal. He's getting his feelings hurt. And that is when one of the students points out, even your own employee says that Dunder
迈克尔说，我不需要说服他们回来。当他们意识到去其他任何地方是一场多大的灾难时，他们最终自然会回来的。然后学生就问，好吧，以前有人回来过吗？迈克尔说，我才不想让他们回来，因为他们都是笨蛋。迈克尔开始把这当成个人攻击了。他的感情受到了伤害。正是在这个时候，其中一个学生指出，甚至你自己的员工都说邓德米夫林
Mifflin is going to be obsolete in five to 10 years. Oh, I mean, this is just like a sucker punch. Michael is so hurt. Yeah. So now back at the office, Dwight has formed an allegiance with Creed. What I love about this, Jenna, is that Dwight couldn't even get a sentence out. He was like, listen, Creed, I need an alliance. He's like, sure.
将在五到十年内过时。哦，我的意思是，这简直就像当胸挨了一拳。迈克尔太受伤了。是的。所以现在回到办公室，德怀特与克里德结成了同盟。我喜欢这一点，珍娜，是因为德怀特甚至连一句话都没完整说出来。他说，听着，克里德，我需要一个同盟。他说，当然。
Like, he is just like, a wretz to go. He is up for it. He has a drawer of tools. So does Dwight. I mean, they're meant to be. Yeah. Dwight asks him, can you turn a wooden mop handle into a steak? And Creed is like, what size?
就像，他简直迫不及待。他完全准备好了。他有一个抽屉的工具。德怀特也是。我的意思是，他们天生一对。是的。德怀特问他，你能把一根木拖把柄削成木桩吗？克里德说，什么尺寸的？
Yeah. He's got a drawer of mung beans and a weaponry, apparently. Well, Jenna, I think this is a great time to take a break because when we come back, Dwight and Creed are going to catch a bat. All right, guys, so Creed and Dwight are on a mission. They are going to catch this bat before 6 p.m., before the professionals of animal control arrive. They're going to take care of this problem.
是的。显然他有一个抽屉的绿豆和武器库。好吧，珍娜，我觉得这是休息一下的好时机，因为当我们回来时，德怀特和克里德要抓住一只蝙蝠。好了，伙计们，所以克里德和德怀特正在执行任务。他们要在下午6点之前，在动物管制的专业人员到达之前抓住这只蝙蝠。他们要解决这个问题。
And Kelly begs them because Creed has now gone into the supply closet. He's grabbing some kind of spray. And Kelly's like, do not hurt that bat. It has feelings, and she just makes this big plea for the bat's safety. And it comes flying into the main area. And then Kelly immediately screams, kill it, kill it, kill it. Yes, exactly. The bat flies into the little kitchen area, and Kevin closes the door.
凯莉求他们，因为克里德现在已经进了杂物间。他抓了一些喷雾剂。凯莉说，不要伤害那只蝙蝠。它有感情，她为蝙蝠的安全进行了大声的恳求。然后它飞到了主区域。接着凯莉立刻尖叫道，杀了它，杀了它，杀了它。是的，没错。蝙蝠飞进了小厨房区，凯文关上了门。
So now that bat is trapped inside, and Kevin is like, oh my gosh, I am a hero. I am a hero. Kevin's day has gone from a near-death experience to being a hero. He is having a day. Why do I feel like that's like Kevin's every day? Every day, Kevin thinks he's a hero over a really mundane thing that's not quite heroic. You might be right. Yeah, I mean, Kevin thinks he saved everyone in the office, but guys, not everyone was
所以现在那只蝙蝠被困在里面了，凯文就像，噢，天哪，我是个英雄。我是个英雄。凯文的一天从濒死体验变成了英雄。他今天过得很充实。为什么我觉得这就像凯文的每一天？每一天，凯文都觉得自己在对一件微不足道、完全谈不上英勇的事情充当英雄。你可能是对的。是的，我的意思是，凯文觉得自己拯救了办公室里的每一个人，但伙计们，并不是所有人都
out of the kitchen. It had gone to the bathroom. Well, we're going to leave her in there for a while because we're going back to Ryan's class. It's getting ugly. It's getting ugly. Michael is grasping at straws. He's so offended.
离开了厨房。它去洗手间了。好吧，我们要把她留在里面一会儿，因为我们要回到瑞恩的课上。情况变得越来越糟了。情况变得越来越糟了。迈克尔在孤注一掷。他太被冒犯了。
He's taking it personal, and he's just started saying all kinds of stuff. Yeah, he's like, guys, this is a David and Goliath situation, but remember, David always wins, and it's just like America. America is facing five Goliaths, five. And then he lists them off. It's like al-Qaeda, global warming, sex predators, mercury poisoning. This is when Michael points out, you know what? Ryan has never made a sale, and he started a fire trying to make a cheesy pita.
他把它当成了个人攻击，他开始胡说八道了。是的，他说，伙计们，这是一个大卫与歌利亚的故事，但记住，大卫总是能赢，这就像美国一样。美国正面临着五个歌利亚，五个。然后他把它们一一列举出来。就像基地组织、全球变暖、性掠夺者、汞中毒。正是在这个时候，迈克尔指出，你知道吗？
That made me laugh out loud. And then he said, and everyone thinks he's a tease. Amazing. And then he says, you know what? Ryan doesn't know anything, and neither do you, so suck on that, and he storms out of the classroom. He is so hurt. If you're Ryan, what are you thinking right now?
瑞恩从来没有做过一笔生意，他为了做一个乳酪皮塔饼还引发了一场火灾。这让我笑得前仰后合。然后他说，每个人都觉得他是个爱挑逗的人。太棒了。然后他说，你知道吗？瑞恩什么都不懂，你们也是，所以给老子吮吸这个吧，然后他气冲冲地走出了教室。他太受伤了。如果你是瑞恩，你现在在想什么？
Because you now know you wrote there with him. You are going to have to ride back to work with this person. That is uncomfortable. Michael tells Ryan business is always personal, Ryan. I mean, that says everything you need to know about Michael, but we know this. Well, I respect that about him. I respect that about Michael, that business isn't business, business is always personal, and that, you know, he's going to say this later, a business is made up of people.
因为你现在知道你和他一起写在那里。你将不得不和这个人一起骑车回去工作。这很不舒服。迈克尔告诉瑞安，公事永远是私事，瑞安。我的意思是，这句话概括了你需要了解的关于迈克尔的一切，但我们很清楚这一点。嗯，我很尊重他这一点。我很尊重迈克尔这一点，公事不是公事，公事永远是私事，而且，你知道的，他等会儿会这么说，一个企业是由人组成的。
I liked it. He tells Ryan, when we get back to the office, you better pack your things. This now starts one of my favorite storylines. Pam is finally at her art show. She's waiting for people to arrive. And we had a fan question. Alex Lane, Ryan Moverly, and Shelly Jones would like to know what kind of discussions occurred regarding Pam's art show outfit.
我很喜欢。他告诉瑞安，等我们回到办公室，你最好收拾好你的东西。这现在开启了我最喜欢的故事线之一。潘终于举办了她的艺术展。她在等人们到来。我们有一个粉丝提问。亚历克斯·莱恩、瑞安·穆弗利和雪莉·琼斯想知道关于潘的艺术展服装曾有过什么样的讨论。
And here, this little like swoopy side ponytail. Pam just is trying to look like she lives, I feel like, in the East Village of New York. Yes. Well, they wanted to know if I had any input into what artsy Pam would look like that night. Oh, yes, I did, and it was so much fun. Harry Bennett and I, we had the best time. She came up with this idea of kind of like this, this beatnik turtleneck, yeah, with the little jumper over top.
还有这里，这个小小的像侧边微卷的马尾。我觉得潘只是在努力打扮得像她住在纽约东村一样。是的。好吧，他们想知道我是否对那天有艺术气息的潘看起来是什么样提出过任何建议。哦，是的，我提过，而且这太有趣了。哈里·贝特尼和我，我们度过了最美好的时光。她想出了这个主意，有点像这种，这种垮掉的一代风格的高领毛衣，是的，外面套着一件小背心。
And then Kim Ferry and I thought, what is the hairstyle that coordinates with this little hipster outfit? And we thought low side pony. And it, I think it works. It's not just any low side pony, though. It's got a little bit of curl. It's kind of relaxed. Yeah.
然后金·费瑞和我思考，与这套小嬉皮士服装相配的发型是什么？我们想到了低侧马尾。而且，我觉得它很搭。不过，这不仅仅是普通的低侧马尾。它带有一点卷度。它有点随性。是的。
Yeah. It's smoothed out. It's not her like frizzy curly hair that we normally see her with. She is ready to walk out of that art show into 1960s something. It's so sweet. I absolutely loved it. And you can see all of Pam's art behind her. It's a series of watercolors of, you know, simple, ordinary items and things, which I
是的。它被梳理得很顺滑。它不是我们平时看到的她那种毛躁卷曲的头发。她准备好走出那个艺术展，步入1960年代的某个时期了。这太可爱了。我绝对喜欢它。你可以看到潘所有的艺术作品都在她身后。这是一系列的水彩画，画的是，你知道的，简单、普通的物品和东西，我觉得
think kind of goes to that whole theme of the show and Pam finding beauty and ordinary things. And I liked the juxtaposition that, you know, Pam's wall is like a coffee mug and a stapler and a vase holding flowers and, you know, a painting of Dunder Mifflin. And then just to the left, whoever's art display that was is like aliens or like an alien robot. Yes. I'm not really sure what it is.
这有点符合该剧的整体主题，以及潘在平常事物中发现美。我喜欢这种并置，你知道的，潘的墙上有咖啡杯、订书机、插着花的瓶子，你知道的，还有一幅邓德米弗林的画。然后就在左边，不管是哪个艺术展示，看起来就像外星人或外星机器人。是的。我不太确定它到底是什么。
Well, we had a fan question from Molly Warner who says, according to Dunderpedia, Joss Whedon was not satisfied with the original art that was produced for Pam at the art show and that new art had to be made. Can you clarify what that original art was and why it had to be changed? Well we asked Brent about this and here's what he told us. What I remember most about Joss Whedon's directing of this episode was a crisis that happened around one of the watercolor drawings that appears in Pam's art show. Now these watercolor drawings were created by the art department at the office and they
嗯，我们有一个来自莫莉·华纳的粉丝提问，她说，根据邓德百科，乔斯·韦登对为潘在艺术展上制作的原版艺术品不满意，必须制作新的艺术品。你能澄清一下那原本的艺术品是什么，以及为什么必须更换吗？嗯，我们问过布伦特这件事，以下是他的讲述。我关于乔斯·韦登执导这一集印象最深的是，围绕着出现在潘的艺术展上的一幅水彩画发生了一场危机。现在这些水彩画是由办公室的艺术部门创作的，它们
appear in the background of all of the shots of Jenna and, you know, as background items they might not seem that important, but when we got on set, there was one drawing that Joss just strongly felt that Pam's character would not have done. It was a watercolor drawing of a church and he just felt it was out of character for her. And you have to imagine when you're shooting a television episode, the time pressure is so intense you do not have time to stop and mess around. And Joss, however, felt so passionately about this picture that he stopped production and said I need a new picture, I would like a picture of a stapler.
出现在珍娜所有镜头的背景中，你知道的，作为背景道具，它们可能看起来没那么重要，但当我们到达片场时，有一幅画乔斯坚决认为潘这个角色是不会画的。那是一幅教堂的水彩画，他只是觉得这不符合她的性格。你必须想象，当你拍摄一集电视剧时，时间压力是如此巨大，你根本没有时间停下来瞎胡闹。然而，乔斯对这幅画有着如此强烈的情感，以至于他叫停了制作，并说我需要一幅新画，我想要一幅订书机的画。
That's what I think that Pam would have drawn. And like I say, the whole production shut down. They brought the executive producer, Greg Daniels, to set. They had a big discussion about it, but Joss would not back down. And we were on location. We didn't have the art department with us. Who was going to draw a picture of a stapler? So the assistant director, we were on a location at a university.
这就是我认为潘会画的东西。正如我所说，整个制作停工了。他们把执行制片人格雷格·丹尼尔斯带到了片场。他们对此进行了激烈的讨论，但乔斯绝不退让。我们在外景地。我们没有艺术部门随行。谁会去画一幅订书机的画呢？所以副导演，我们在大学的一个外景地。
The assistant director went into a classroom full of art students and said, is anyone here able to draw a watercolor of a stapler? And they pulled some young woman out and they paid her 50 bucks or something. And she just cranked out this picture of a stapler that you see in the background of all of Pam's shots. And afterwards, I was riding back in the van to home base with Joss. And I said, Joss, what was all that about? Why did you get so intense about this?
副导演走进一间坐满艺术学生的教室，说，这里有人能画一张订书机的用水彩画吗？他们拉出一个年轻女子，给了她50块钱左右。她就这样赶制出了你在潘的所有镜头背景中看到的这幅订书机画。之后，我和乔斯坐面包车回大本营。我对他说，乔斯，那到底是怎么回事？你为什么对这个这么较真？
And he said, Brent, in my experience as a director, every single time that I have felt strongly about some detail of the shoot, and I have allowed myself to be persuaded out of it because of time pressure 100% of the time I have intensely regretted making that choice. And so now I understand that I should never compromise when I feel something strongly as a director. It's a great lesson in my limited experience as a director. I've never forgotten it.
他说，布伦特，根据我作为导演的经验，每当我对拍摄的某个细节有强烈感觉，并且由于时间压力，我允许自己被说服放弃它时百分之百的时候，我都对做出那个选择感到无比后悔。所以我现在明白了，当我作为一个导演对某事有强烈感觉时，我绝不应该妥协。这是我作为导演的有限经验中的一个伟大教训。我永远不会忘记它。
I think it's a really good lesson for all of us as artists. Stick to your guns. If you feel it passionately, you're probably right. I have to say, Angela, the watercolor that stood out to me the most when we first flash up to her wall was that stapler. Yeah. Me too. It was absolutely what Pam would have done because we already established she's sort
我认为这对我们所有作为艺术家的所有人来说都是一个非常好的教训。坚持你的立场。如果你对它充满热情，你很可能是对的。我不得不说，安吉拉，当我们第一次把目光投向她的墙上时，最让我瞩目的水彩画就是那个订书机。是的。我也是。这绝对是潘会做的事，因为我们已经确定她有点
of drawing things in her world and she sketched a tape dispenser. It would make sense to me. And then, you know, Jim, I feel like that stapler also represents Jim. Jim put that stapler in Dwight's Jell-O mold, you know? I never thought of that. Yeah, that's what I thought. I thought Pam painted that stapler because she was thinking of Jim. I just got chills.
在画她世界里的东西，她画过胶带座的草图。这对我来说说得通。然后，你知道的，吉姆，我觉得那个订书机也代表了吉姆。吉姆把那个订书机放进了德怀特的果冻模具里，你知道吗？我从来没想过这个。是的，我是这么想的。我以为潘画那个订书机是因为她想到了吉姆。我顿时起了一身鸡皮疙瘩。
Well, I got a little low down on the Dunder Mifflin painting from Kentopedia. He said that that is not actually a watercolor, but it was a photograph of our building that they manipulated to look like a watercolor. Oh, like just some fancy kind of graphics. Yeah. So no one ever did a from blank page watercolor of the building. You know, that time, a while back, Jenna invited me to do a wine and canvas night. And it was so fun.
嗯，我从肯特百科上得到了关于邓德米弗林画作的一些内幕消息。他说那实际上不是水彩画，而是我们大楼的照片，他们对其进行了处理，使其看起来像水彩画。哦，就像某种花哨的图形处理。是的。所以从来没有人从一张白纸开始画过这座大楼的水彩画。你知道，那次，前不久，珍娜邀请我去参加一个红酒与画布之夜。这太有趣了。
It was like in a part of a mall, like you entered from outside, right? Yeah. It was a mall in Pasadena. Yeah. And we went and you kind of just sort of pick a random night to go and I wasn't really sure what we were painting and then we found out we were painting cats on a fence at nighttime. And I still have mine. My husband loves it so much he hung it by where he feeds the cats so the cats see the
它好像在商场的一部分，就像从外面进去的，对吧？是的。那是帕萨迪纳的一个商场。是的。我们去了，你差不多就是随便挑一个晚上去，我其实不确定我们要画什么，然后我们发现我们在画夜里的栅栏上的猫。我到现在还留着我的那幅。我丈夫非常喜欢它，他把它挂在他喂猫的地方旁边，这样猫在吃晚餐时就能看到
cats on the fence as they eat their dinner. It's kind of funny. But I became sort of really interested in this wine and canvas night. We were talking about doing another one, maybe inviting a few friends. I found that they do wine and canvas and everyone can paint the Dunder Mifflin building. Oh my gosh. That is amazing. Wouldn't you want to do that?
栅栏上的猫。这挺搞笑的。但我开始对这个红酒与画布之夜真的很感兴趣。我们在讨论再去一次，也许邀请几个朋友。我发现他们有红酒与画布活动，每个人都可以画邓德米弗林大楼。哦，天哪。这太棒了。难道你不想去吗？
I would love to do that. Angela, I think it would be really weird if you and I showed up at a wine and canvas and painted Dunder Mifflin. There's like a room of people like you sign up. We showed up. There were probably 30 people there and we had a little seating assignment. We had our canvas in our paints and then they pass around wine and the teachers at the front she had a headset on remember so we could all hear.
我很想去。安吉拉，我觉得如果你和我出现在红酒与画布活动上并画了邓德米弗林，那会非常诡异。就像有一个房间的人，你报名了。我们出现了。那里大概有30个人，我们有固定的座位分配。我们有我们的画布和颜料，然后他们传递红酒，前台的老师戴着耳机，你还记得吧，这样我们都能听到。
So you and I would be in a room with like 30 other people, total strangers. I totally remember it because my daughter has always from the time she was born loved cats. She loves cats. And I knew she was going to love this painting and I didn't want my son to feel left out when I came home from my painting night. So on my canvas, I added a little spaceship out in the sky because he loved outer space. So I was like, okay, well, this will bring him into this painting and we have it in our
所以你和我将和一个大约有30个其他人的房间在一起，全都是陌生人。我完全记得，因为我的女儿从出生起就一直很喜欢猫。她喜欢猫。我知道她会喜欢这幅画，而且我不想让我的儿子在我从画画之夜回家时感到被冷落。所以在我的画布上，我在天空中加了一个小飞船，因为他喜欢外太空。所以我当时想，好吧，这会把他带入这幅画中，我们把它挂在我们的
playroom. I love it. Hanging up. But I do. I want to do a wine and canvas night and I want to paint Dunder Mifflin, Jenna. I can't say I want to do that. You don't want to paint Dunder Mifflin? I know.
游戏室里。我太喜欢了。挂在那里。但我确实想去。我想参加一个红酒与画布之夜，我想画邓德米弗林，珍娜。我不能说我想去。你不想画邓德米弗林吗？我知道。
Well, you have it, don't you? You own it. I do. I already have it. You own it and I was going to leave that for the end. You own it. But also, Jenna, what if your painting was horrible? I hope you're attentive to painting Dunder Mifflin.
嗯，你不是已经有了吗？那是你的。我有。我早就有勒。这是你的，我本来打算把它留到最后说。是你的。不过话说回来，珍娜，如果你的画画得一塌糊涂呢？我希望你对画邓德米弗林保持专注。
No, I'm kidding. Well, I will say this too, in this pandemic, my daughter's gotten really into watercolor painting and so it's very funny to me that I, as Jenna, am now sitting around every day doing watercolor paintings like my character Pam did and I think I've gotten really good at doing flowers. I've actually watched some tutorial videos. Well maybe I'll watch a tutorial video on painting Dunder Mifflin and I'll... There must be one.
不，我开玩笑的。不过我也会这么说，在这场大流行期间，我女儿迷上了水彩画，所以对我来说非常有趣的是，我，作为珍娜，现在每天都坐在那里画水彩画，就像我的角色潘所做的那样，而且我觉得我在画花方面变得真的很擅长。我实际上看过一些教程视频。也许我会看一个关于画邓德米弗林的教程视频，我会……肯定有一个。
I'll paint it and show it to you. There you go. Okay. Sorry. Where are we, lady? Well, back at Dunder Mifflin, Meredith is still hiding from the bat and everyone is just leaving for the day. Everyone's like, bye.
我会把它画出来展示给你。那就这样吧。好的。抱歉。女士们，我们现在到哪儿了？嗯，回到邓德米弗林，梅雷迪思还在躲着蝙蝠，大家正准备下班离开。每个人都在说，再见。
Crete is like, later, Marybeth. Yes, people wanted to know if that was improvisation, no, that was scripted. Well, there are a few deleted scenes that happen right here, Jenna, that are worth mentioning. One is that there's a few cutaways that they didn't have time for of Meredith trying to leave the bathroom and then seeing the bat screaming and going back in. Oh, okay. You know, so kind of playing up the fact that she really does feel trapped and she really is scared.
克里特说，回见，玛丽贝思。是的，人们想知道那是不是即兴发挥，不，那是剧本写好的。嗯，这里有几个删减片段，珍娜，很值得一提。一个是，有些镜头由于时间关系被剪掉了，关于梅雷迪思试图离开洗手间，然后看到蝙蝠尖叫着又跑了回去。哦，好吧。你知道的，这有点烘托出她确实觉得自己被困住了而且真的很害怕。
Okay. And then there's a scene of Dwight looking through the blinds and screaming at her. So there's this sort of like buildup of this moment. And then the other scene that I love that's deleted is, as everyone's leaving for the day, leaving Meredith trapped, Angela and Kelly exit together. And Angela says, just goes to show you the power of prayer. And Kelly says, you prayed for this? And Angela says, in a general sense.
好的。然后还有一个德怀特透过百叶窗看着她并向她尖叫的场景。所以这有点像在为这个时刻做铺垫。然后我喜欢的另一个被删掉的场景是，当大家下班离开，留下梅雷迪思被困在里面时，安吉拉和凯莉一起出去了。安吉拉说，这正好说明了祈祷的力量。凯莉说，你为这个祈祷了？安吉拉说，在通常意义上。
Oh, my goodness. So did I pray that Meredith needs some kind of reckoning and it's going to happen? Wow. I know. I guess Angela maybe prayed that she would be scared into better behavior. Yes. And this is, she feels the answer to her prayer. Better lifestyle choices, Meredith.
哦，天哪。所以我祈祷梅雷迪思需要某种报应，而且它会发生吗？哇。我知道。我猜安吉拉可能祈祷她能被吓得表现好一点。是的。这就是她觉得对她祈祷的回应。过上更好的生活方式吧，梅雷迪思。
So now we have the scene, the scene of Dwight going in to capture this bat. And it ends up landing on Meredith's head. So he has to put a trash bag over her head with the bat inside and kind of like wrestle her around. In Sanity, well, you know, we got a lot of mail about this one, Angela, Monica Sweeney, Jessica Bone, Ashley McGuettrick, Erin Westra and Raphael Bresselsmith. And I mean, just countless others said the scene with Dwight trapping the bat on Meredith's head looked so real.
所以现在我们有了这个场景，德怀特进去捕捉这只蝙蝠的场景。结果它落在了梅雷迪思的头上。所以他必须把一个垃圾袋套在她头上，里面装着蝙蝠，然后有点像跟她扭打在一起。疯狂，好吧，你知道的，我们收到了很多关于这个场景的邮件，安吉拉，莫妮卡·斯威尼、杰西卡·博恩、阿什利·麦克格特里克、埃琳·韦斯特拉和拉斐尔·布雷瑟史密斯。我的意思是，还有无数其他人说德怀特把蝙蝠困在梅雷迪思头上的场景看起来太真实了。
How did they do it? Well, we asked Kate to tell us all about the scene and she told us she worked with both a real bat and a mechanical bat. Here's what else she had to say. Yes. We had a real bat with like five handlers. I wish I had five handlers. Yes.
他们是怎么做到的？嗯，我们请凯特给我们讲讲这个场景的一切，她告诉我们她同时用了一只真正的蝙蝠和一只机械蝙蝠。她还有这些话要说。是的。我们有一只真正的蝙蝠，配了大约五个驯养员。我希望我有五个驯养员。是的。
But we were not letting any noise around the bat. I couldn't scream. So even though I was screaming, I was acting like I was screaming when we were shooting because I don't know if that's something about the sonar. And then we had this motorized thing that I had on my head that we actually did have a stunt double. But gee, I don't really think they used her and maybe one little shot with her in it, one cut away.
但我们不容许蝙蝠周围有任何噪音。我不能尖叫。所以即使我在尖叫，我们在拍摄时我也只是假装在尖叫，因为我不知道这是否跟声纳有关。然后我们有一个装在我头上的电动装置，我们其实确实有一个特技替身。但是天哪，我觉得他们真的没用她，可能只有一个有她的小镜头，一个切出镜头。
But I did all of it. The motorized thing on the head, it was like sort of like this fluttery thing, it was almost like a headband with a motor. And then there was a human being with like a puppy thing with a stick. He was on his knees and he was trying to put the stick up my skirt before he introduced himself, which whatever, I mean, a little out of order. And yes, I could breathe with the bag over my head. We figured it out.
但我把所有的都做了。头上的那个电动装置，它有点像这种会扇动的东东，几乎就像是一个带马达的发带。然后有一个人拿着一个带棍子的玩偶。他跪在地上，在自我介绍之前试图把棍子从我的裙子底下伸进去，不管怎样，我的意思是，有点顺序颠倒。是的，头上套着袋子我也能呼吸。我们想出办法了。
It was fine. So I was acting like that. And it was one of the most fun scenes I got to do with Rain because he is an amazing actor and he goes for it, man. But I am not afraid. I have never been afraid of Rain Wolf's or Dwight Trude. So that is, that's it, save that time, save that channel. I was going to say that for you.
没问题。所以我当时就在那样演。这是我和雷恩一起拍的最有趣的场景之一，因为他是一个出色的演员，而且他全力以赴，老兄。但我并不害怕。我从来都不害怕雷恩·威尔恩斯或者德怀特·舒鲁特。所以就这样，保存那个时间，保存那个频道。我本来想为你留着这句话的。
Yeah, I guess Phil Shea got this mechanical bat, like a battery operated Halloween toy and they put it on a headband on her head because it really does look like there are wings flapping inside that bag. It was what a good, just old fashioned movie magic moment. Yeah, it was like some new technology and old tech all came together. Yes. I have a memory Jenna of like Kim Ferry and Phil Shea working on that headband. Like, like he, I remember it in her hair and makeup area.
是的，我猜菲尔·谢伊弄到了这只机械蝙蝠，就像一个电池供电的万圣节玩具，他们把它放在她头上的发带上，因为袋子里看起来确实有翅膀在扇动。这真是一个美好、老派的电影魔术时刻。是的，这就像一些新技术和旧技术的结合。是的。珍娜，我有一个记忆，就像金·费瑞和菲尔·谢伊在弄那个发带。就像，他，我记得在她的发型和化妆区。
Do you like, she was like sort of like, yes, let's sing with it and stuff. She had it on one of those little mannequins and he was in there with the little battery operated controls explaining how it would work and they would put a bag over it and they would test it. I remember that too. We must have been in there in the trailer when they were doing that. I have that same memory. Oh man.
你觉得，她当时就像是，是的，让我们用它来唱歌什么的。她把它戴在那些小人体模型之一上，他拿着带电池的操作开关在那里解释它是如何工作的，然后他们会把一个袋子套在上面并进行测试。我也记得那一幕。我们当时一定在他们做这件事时的化妆车里。我有同样的记忆。哦，天哪。
And then on top of it, there was a guy with a stick and a puppet. My God. What was that about? Well, I know. I mean, Kate said like he had to put a stick up her skirt. Like maybe they, they had all these different ways the bat might be under the bag. Anyway, well done everyone. It was a team effort, but I thought that scene was fantastic.
不仅如此，还有一个拿着棍子和玩偶的家伙。天哪。那是什么情况？嗯，我知道。我的意思是，凯特说他必须把棍子伸进她的裙子底下。就像可能他们，他们有各种不同的方式来模拟蝙蝠可能在袋子下面。无论如何，大家干得好。这是一次团队合作，但我认为那个场景棒极了。
Well the other thing she said in her clip too, Angela, was about how she wasn't allowed to actually scream. Yes. So when I heard that, I remembered that from our big group scene with the bat. Yes, I did too. When rain sort of like pokes the ceiling up, the real bat is up there. That shot was the real bat and we all had to be silent. And I remember we had to be super silent as they brought the bat in and placed the bat.
嗯，她在短片中说的另一件事，安吉拉，是关于她其实不被允许尖叫。是的。所以当我听到这个时，我想起了我们跟蝙蝠的那场大型群戏。是的，我也是。当雷恩有点像往天花板上戳时，真的蝙蝠就在上面。那个镜头是真正的蝙蝠，我们所有人都必须保持安静。我记得当他们把蝙蝠带进来并安放好时，我们必须保持超级安静。
And then when they removed the bat before we started doing all of our screaming and reacting to nothing. Yeah. That happens a lot with animals. I worked with a squirrel where you had to be super quiet around the squirrel. Really? Yeah. No sudden movements around the squirrel.
然后当他们在我们开始尖叫和对着空气做出反应之前把蝙蝠移走的时候。是的。这种情况在动物身上经常发生。我曾和一只松鼠合作过，你必须在松鼠周围保持超级安静。真的吗？是的。在松鼠周围不能有突然的动作。
Okay. So now we're back at Pam's art show and Roy has come and he's brought his brother. Yes. And you know, Roy has just regressed, right? He says all of this stuff that is so insulting. He's like, oh, hey, look at this, like no one else showed up, but I came and I brought someone. That's pretty cool.
好的，现在我们回到了潘的艺术展，罗伊来了，他还带了他的兄弟。是的。而且你知道，罗伊简直是在退步，对吧？他说所有这些非常侮辱人的话。他说，哦，嘿，看这个，好像别人都没来，但我来了，我还带了个人。这挺酷的。
Well, you know, I don't know if it's Roy regressing or is he just trying in his very lame attempt here to say, Pam, look, you know, I show up for you, but I know, but like what is he needs a big congratulations for showing up to his girlfriend's art show? Like you're doing the bare minimum. Roy at his real true self is going to make the most basic amount of effort and expect that to be enough and even applauded. Roy is the type of man who needs to be thanked profusely for doing everyday chores like the dishes and taking out the trash as if he's done something extraordinary, but really you're
嗯，你知道的，我不知道这到底是罗伊在退步，还是他只是用他极其拙劣的方式在这里说，潘，你看，你知道的，我会为你出现，但我知道，但是像他为什么需要为出席女朋友的艺术展而获得热烈的祝贺？就像你做的是最基本的事情。罗伊以他最真实的自我，会付出最少量的努力，并期望这就足够了，甚至还希望能得到掌声。罗伊就是那种需要因为做日常杂务（比如洗碗和倒垃圾）而受到极力感谢的男人，就好像他做了什么了不起的事一样，但实际上你
just contributing to the partnership of running a household. Yeah. I changed a light bulb. Yeah. Oh my gosh. Thank you. Meanwhile, Roy is not probably thanking Pam for everything she's doing to contribute to running the household.
只是在为维系一个家庭的伙伴关系做出贡献。是的。我换了一个灯泡。是的。哦，天哪。谢谢。与此同时，罗伊可能并没有感谢潘为维系家庭所做的一切贡献。
That's the dynamic that Pam has to look forward to if she follows through on this. Well, I definitely think this art show night, she's raw, she's feeling vulnerable and she needs Roy to be more of a support and he's just not able. And I think that's the reality. Roy is going to be a great partner to someone else that doesn't need the same things from him that Pam needs. Well, as he's leaving, he tells her this famous line, which is that her art is the prettiest art of all the art.
如果潘真的把这进行到底，这就是她不得不面对的动态关系。嗯，我绝对认为这个艺术展之夜，她的内心是生涩的，她感到脆弱，她需要罗伊给予更多的支持，而他根本做不到。我觉得这就是现实。罗伊会成为另一个不需要他提供潘所需要的东西的人的伟大伴侣。嗯，当他离开时，他告诉了她这句名言，那就是她的艺术是所有艺术中最美的艺术。
Thank you, Roy for that nugget. So I do have a little post-it and I wrote on it, I'm sorry, is this some Gil sass? Yes, some Gil sass. Yes, because Oscar and Gil show up to the art show. They don't know that Pam has walked up behind them and Gil is really kind of going off on your art. He's like, listen, real art takes courage and honesty and this is motel art. And Oscar says those aren't Pam's strong points.
谢谢罗伊提供这个金句。所以我确实有一张便签，我在上面写着，对不起，这是吉尔在阴阳怪气吗？是的，吉尔的毒舌。是的，因为奥斯卡和吉尔出现在艺术展上。他们不知道潘已经走到了他们身后，而吉尔真的在对你的艺术评头论足。他说，听着，真正的艺术需要勇气和诚实，而这是汽车旅馆艺术。奥斯卡说这些可不是潘的长处。
I think all of that hits her so harsh. I think it's even more powerful for Pam to hear because in this moment, she's forced to hold up a mirror to her life and part of that courage and honesty is finally boldly saying Roy is not my person. Well, Angela, earlier in this episode, Pam declares that being back with Roy shows maturity and dignity, remember, and she's like, oh, I hope that didn't sound braggy. But when she hears this from Gil and Oscar, she's being confronted with the fact that getting back with Roy does not show dignity or honesty or courage.
我觉得所有这些对她的打击都太严厉了。我认为这对于潘来说听到这些更有冲击力，因为在这个时刻，她被迫对着生活照一面镜子，而那勇气和诚实的一部分就是最终勇敢地说出罗伊不是我的真命天子。嗯，安吉拉，在这集的早些时候，潘宣称回到罗伊身边展现了成熟和尊严，你还记得吧，她还说，哦，我希望听起来不要像是在炫耀。但当她从吉尔和奥斯卡那里听到这些时，她正面临着这样一个事实：回到罗伊身边并没有展现出尊严、诚实或勇气。
Yeah, and I feel like it's one of these beautiful moments on our show where, you know, on the one hand, we're talking about her art. But on the other hand, for Pam, it's like this self realization about her choices in her life. Well, you kind of think that it can't get lower for Pam because her only two visitors have been Roy and his brother and Oscar and Gil. And then she's standing there alone. The evening is winding down.
是的，我觉得这是我们剧里美好的时刻之一，你知道的，一方面，我们在谈论她的艺术。但另一方面，对潘来说，这就像是对她人生选择的一种自我觉悟。嗯，你有点觉得潘的人生不能再跌入低谷了，因为她仅有的两个访客是罗伊和他的兄弟，还有奥斯卡和吉尔。然后她独自站在那里。傍晚渐近尾声。
She starts to take her art off the wall. But then Michael walks in and we hear Pam Casso and you're like, oh, no, oh, no, is this going to be good or bad? He's started off with Pam Casso. Yeah, it's like, wow. And I think that's Pam's reaction. Pam's like, oh, Michael, you came and but it's kind of like, I don't even know if I can do this, but Michael is immediately just so taken with her art.
她开始把墙上的艺术品取下来。但接着迈克尔走了进来，我们听到“潘加索”，你会想，哦，不，哦，不，这到底是好还是坏？他一开口就是“潘加索”。是的，就像是，哇。我想这也是潘的反应。潘就像是，哦，迈克尔，你来了，但这有点像，我甚至不知道我能不能做到这一点，但迈克尔立刻就被她的艺术深深吸引了。
And some of this is because of what he's been through today. You know, Michael doesn't know what Pam's been through and Pam doesn't know what Michael's been through. But in this moment, these two human beings are coming together and they heal one another. Yeah. And these two are coming together a little hurt and broken from the day. And this is such a beautiful scene, Jenna. I just love all the beats of it.
这其中有一部分是因为他今天经历的事情。你知道的，迈克尔不知道潘经历了什么，潘也不知道迈克尔经历了什么。但在这一刻，这两个人走到了一起，他们治愈了彼此。是的。这两个人带着一点白天的伤痛和破碎走到一起，这是一个非常美好的场景，珍娜。我太喜欢其中的每一个节拍了。
I love how excited Michael is. I love how moved Pam is by his excitement. And he sees that her car and his car, she painted both of them. And it's just such a sweet scene. We had a lot of people write in. Mary Ruff, Soraya Garlip, Madison Schnirpel, Stacy Dull and Layla Baroka all asked, Jenna, how did you prepare for the level of emotion you had to play in this scene when Michael shows up and tells Pam that he's proud of her?
我喜欢迈克尔有多兴奋。我喜欢潘被他的兴奋感动成什么样。他看到她的车和他的车，她把两辆车都画了。这真是一个温馨的场景。我们有很多观众写信来。玛丽·拉夫、索雷亚·加利普、麦迪逊·施尼尔佩尔、斯泰西·达尔和莱拉·巴罗卡都问，珍娜，当迈克尔出现并告诉潘他为她感到骄傲时，你是如何为这个场景中你需要表现出的情感水平做准备的？
Did you stay in that emotion during the breaks? And if not, was it hard to get back between takes? Guys, I will tell you, I didn't have to prepare much for this. Because my scene partner was Steve Carell. And the relationship that I had with Steven real life, and I think Angela, this is a little bit for you too. He was someone I looked up to in the way that you look up to a mentor or a parent. And I admired him so much.
在休息期间你一直保持那种情感吗？如果不是，在拍摄间隙很难找回状态吗？伙计们，我告诉你们，我其实不需要为这个做太多准备。因为我的对手戏演员是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔。我在现实生活中与史蒂夫的关系，我想安吉拉，这也有一点适用于你。他是我仰慕的人，就像你仰慕一位导师或一位家长那样。我非常崇拜他。
So just to have him look at me and say, I'm proud of you, I just started crying. His sincerity and his truth in saying it, he's a wonderful actor and it was easy, easy. He's just such a special person. So to have moments like that with him, the emotion is pretty ready to go. I did this appearance on busy Phillips talk show. On busy tonight. I remember. Yeah.
所以只要他看着我说，我为你感到骄傲，我就直接哭出来了。他说这话时的真诚和真实，他是一个出色的演员，这太容易了，太容易了。他真的是一个很特别的人。所以能和有过这样的时刻，那种情感可以说是信手拈来。我在比茜·菲利普斯的脱口秀上做过一次嘉宾。在《今夜比茜》。我记得。是的。
And it was like around my birthday. And she had secretly called people from the office to send in gifts for me and you sent in a shirt with a loaf of bread on it. Here's the crazy thing. She reached out to me. She was like, Angie, I want to do this. What do you think? I am literally online buying her a t-shirt with a loaf of bread on it.
那大约是在我生日前后。她秘密地打电话给办公室的人让他们给我寄礼物，你寄了一件印有一条面包的衬衫。疯狂的事情是这样的。她联系了我。她就像是，安吉拉，我想做这件事。你觉得呢？我当时真的在网上给她买了一件印有一条面包的T恤。
And she was like, oh my God, can we have that? So it was this total surprise and I get all these presents and this whole time that I've been doing this talk show appearance, the entire time there has been a giant box sitting on the set for like 20 minutes, right? 20 minutes. Yeah. And at the end of the segment, she says, well, we have one last gift for you. And it's this giant box and the box pops open and Steve Carell pops out of the box.
然后她就像是，哦，天哪，我们能用那个吗？所以这是一个完全的惊喜，我得到了所有这些礼物，而我做这个脱口秀嘉宾的整个期间，片场一直放着一个巨大的箱子，大概有20分钟吧？20分钟。是的。在环节结束时，她说，好吧，我们有最后一件礼物要送给你。这是一个巨大的箱子，箱子突然打开，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔从箱子里跳了出来。
First of all, I was so scared because I wasn't expecting a human being to come out of the box. And then as soon as I saw that it was Steve, I just like immediately burst into tears. He had sat in a box for like 20 minutes while I droned on giving this interview. Just to surprise me for my birthday. I don't know, it's like that's Steve, you guys. It was such a just generous, like kind, loving thing to do. So you just have to, that's how he's always been.
首先，我吓坏了，因为我没料到一个大活人会从箱子里跳出来。然后我一看到是史蒂夫，我就立刻泪崩了。我在喋喋不休地做这个采访时，他居然在一个箱子里坐了大约20分钟。就为了给我一个生日惊喜。我不知道，这就是史蒂夫，你们懂的。这是一个多么慷慨、善良、充满爱意的举动。所以你只需要，他一直以来都是这样。
So in this moment, shooting the scene with him or any emotional scene with him, it's all just right there. I love that so much, Jenna. I hope people can still watch that because that moment is so sweet. And you start to cry and Steve is smiling and you guys hug and you say, how long have you been in here? And he's like for a while because they had to set that box before you came out. Yes.
所以在这一刻，跟他拍这场戏或跟他拍任何情感戏，一切就都在那里了。我太喜欢这个了，珍娜。我希望人们还能看到那个画面，因为那个时刻太美妙了。你开始哭，史蒂夫在笑，你们拥抱在一起，你问，你在这里呆了多久了？他说呆了一会儿，因为他们得在你出来之前把那个箱子摆好。是的。
So he was there before the interview and through the whole interview. Yes. Well, we asked Brent about the art show and how they created this moment between Michael and Pam and Jenna, you might want to buckle in because get ready for a love fest from Brent Forrester. When people ask me, what is my favorite episode of TV that I have ever written? I always say business school. And partly it's because the episode is so nicely designed.
所以他在采访开始前和整个采访过程中都在里面。是的。嗯，我们问了布伦特关于艺术展以及他们是如何创造迈克尔和潘之间的这个时刻的，珍娜，你可能得系好安全带了，因为准备好迎接布伦特·福斯特的赞美狂潮吧。当人们问我，我写过的最喜欢的电视剧集是什么时？我总是说是商学院。部分原因是因为这一集设计得太巧妙了。
It's got that big comedy C story with the bat and the vampire. It's got a big comedy performance story with Michael going to business school. But above all, it has this tremendous emotional story with Pam's art show. I think that what is happening in Pam's art show is one of those wonderful coincidences of the experience of the writer, me and the actress, Jenna, coming together. If you try to be an artist of any kind, a writer, an actress, any artist at all, you have to believe in yourself so profoundly and inevitably there will come moments of failure where your belief in yourself is dashed.
它有关于蝙蝠和吸 vampires 的重磅喜剧C故事。它有迈克尔去商学院的重磅喜剧表演故事。但最重要的是，它有关于潘的艺术展的巨大情感故事。我认为潘的艺术展上发生的事情是编剧（我）和演员（珍娜）的经历之间绝妙的巧合之一。如果你试图成为任何形式的艺术家，编剧、演员，任何艺术家，你都必须如此深刻地相信自己，而不可避免地会有失败的时刻，让你对自己的自信心受到打击。
And it is so painful and unforgettable when it happens to a human being. And I think it's really what Jenna is expressing at the end of this episode. If you read her tremendous book, An Actor's Life, which is both an instructional manual and a riveting autobiography, you will learn that Jenna Fisher spent seven years trying to break into the business of acting. At the end of seven years, she felt that she had failed. She packed up her car and she decided she was going to return home to Missouri. She was only persuaded to stay by her acting coach and her manager who said, please, Jenna,
当这种事发生在一个人类身上时，它是如此痛苦且难以忘怀。我想这正是珍娜在这集结尾时所表达的。如果你读过她那本精彩的书《演员的生活》（An Actor's Life），它既是一本教学手册又是一部引人入胜的自传，你就会知道珍娜·费舍尔花了七年时间试图闯入演艺界。七年结束时，她觉得自己失败了。她收拾好车，决定回密苏里老家。她只是在她的表演教练和经纪人的劝说下才留了下来，他们说，求求你，珍娜，
spend one more season trying out for TV. And that's when she got the office. But that experience of terrible defeat is something that I believe she never forgot. And it's what she's expressing at the end of this episode. Steve Carell says that when he watches business school, that moment where Michael Scott hugs Pam and there's a close on her face. Steve says he can see five different emotions play through Jenna's face in that performance. It is heartbreak and it is gratitude.
再花一个季度去试镜电视剧吧。也就是在那时她得到了办公室。但我相信那场惨败的经历是她永远不会忘记的。这正是她在这集结尾时所表达的。史蒂夫·卡瑞尔说，当他看商学院时，迈克尔·斯科特拥抱潘的那个时刻，镜头特写在她的脸上。史蒂夫说他能在那场表演中看到珍娜脸上有五种不同的情感闪过。那是心碎，也是感激。
It is just the whole human experience wrapped up in a single take. It's a tremendous performance. And it's part of why I will always be so grateful that I got to write this episode for one of my favorite actresses of all time, Jenna Fisher. Oh my gosh, Brent. What are you going to say after that? That is the most beautiful thing ever, like Jenna, that is so lovely. You know what?
它只是把整个人类的经历浓缩在一个镜头里。这是一场精彩绝伦的表演。这也是为什么我永远会如此感激我能为我最喜欢的女演员之一珍娜·费舍尔写这一集的原因。哦，天哪，布伦特。你听了这话之后还要说啥？这是史上最美好的事情，就像珍娜，这太美好了。你知道吗？
I am going to save that and I'm going to listen to that any time I am having a bad day. Because that really, thank you, that lifts me up. Jenna, I have been at all of your big life moments. Really I have. I have heard toast and speeches about you and that's probably the best. I was at your wedding. Brent should have given a toast at your wedding. Clearly.
我要把它存起来，每当我度过糟糕的一天时我都要听听这个。因为这真的，谢谢你，这让我振作起来。珍娜，我见证了你人生中所有的重大时刻。真的，我见证过。我听过关于你的祝酒词和演讲，而这可能是最棒的一次。我参加了你的婚礼。布伦特本应该在你的婚礼上致祝酒词的。显然。
Clearly. Oh my gosh. He like recaptured your book and your whole life experience. And then what Steve said was so beautiful. I mean, Jenna, Brent was going on for so long. He ran out of air. Did you hear? At the end he had to go, he was so passionate talking about you.
显然。哦，天哪。他就像是重述了你的书和你整个人生经历。然后史蒂夫说的话太美妙了。我的意思是，珍娜，布伦特说得太久了。他都喘不上气了。你听到了吗？最后他不得不停下来，他在谈论你时太充满激情了。
Something he said is true. There's one thing I never actually packed up my car and said I was going to leave. But I did say, I called my managers after seven years of failures and said, I've decided to become a vet technician. I had signed up. It was a two year program. I had been doing some animal rescue and I was going to do it full time. And I wanted my vet tech license so that I could administer medicines.
他说的有一件事是真的。其实有一件事我从未真正收拾好车说我要离开。但我确实说过，在经历了七年的失败后，我给我的经纪人们打电话说，我决定成为一名兽医技术员。我已经报名了。这是一个两年制的项目。我一直在做一些动物救援工作，我打算全职做这个。我想要我的兽医技术员执照，这样我就可以管理药物了。
And so I was like, I'm out of here. And it is true that my manager and my acting coach sort of yelled at me. And they were like, what did you think an acting career was? You thought it was just a bunch of ups? Just a bunch of, just a bunch of successes? No, it's little successes followed by many failures. This is what being an actor is. And it's true what Brent says too, which is that I did channel a lot of those struggling
所以我当时想，我要离开这里。而且我的经纪人和我的表演教练确实对我大喊大叫了一番，这是真的。他们就像是，你以为演艺生涯是什么？你以为它只是一连串的高潮吗？只是一连串的，只是一连串的成功吗？不，它是由许多失败伴随着的小成功组成的。这就是当演员的意义所在。布伦特说的也是真的，那就是我确实把那些挣扎的岁月融入到了对潘的表演中。
years into my performance for Pam. I literally sat at a reception desk and dreamed of being an artist. I have done that. I did it for seven years. So I deeply, deeply felt Pam's longing. Yeah. Brent also sent us in an audio clip where he discussed just the overall story for this episode with Pam and Michael and why he thinks that it resonates so much with people.
我真的坐在接待台前梦想成为一名艺术家。我做过那种事。我做了七年。所以我深深地、深深地感受到了潘的渴望。嗯，布伦特还给我们发来了一段音频剪辑，他在其中讨论了这一集关于潘和迈克尔的整体故事，以及为什么他认为这会引起人们的强烈共鸣。
And here's what he had to say about that. I remember before I was sent off to write this episode, I got into a big debate with Greg Daniels, the show creator about the story of Pam's art show. And I at the time thought of myself as a sophisticated storyteller. And I took the position that this story did not work because I said to Greg, a story is about a protagonist pursuing a goal, overcoming obstacles, and in the end accomplishing that goal. And in this case, Pam's goal is to be respected as an artist.
以下是他对此的看法。我记得在我被派去写这一集之前，我和剧集创作者格雷格·丹尼尔斯就潘的艺术展的故事展开了一场激烈的辩论。我当时认为自己是一个成熟的叙事者。我持有的立场是，这个故事行不通，因为我对格雷格说，一个故事是关于主角追求目标、克服障碍，并在最后完成该目标的。而在这种情况下，潘的目标是作为一名艺术家受到尊重。
But when Michael Scott buys her painting at the end, it doesn't resolve her problem because she does not respect Michael Scott's taste. If so, facto, her problem is not resolved and the story does not work. And I remember Greg saying to me, Brent, this is a sophisticated story with a sophisticated ending. It would be like this. Suppose you, Brent, were the protagonist and your goal was to impress me with your storytelling abilities, but you said something so stupid in the breaking of this story that
但当迈克尔·斯科特在最后买下她的画时，并没有解决她的问题，因为她不尊重迈克尔·斯科特的品味。因此，她的问题没有解决，这个故事就行不通。我记得格雷格对我说，布伦特，这是一个成熟的故事，有着成熟的结局。它就像这样。假设你，布伦特，是主角，你的目标是用你的讲故事能力打动我，但你在构思这个故事时说了一些如此愚蠢的话，以至于
I fired you and sent you home. You went home miserable and not having accomplished your goal. But your family dog came up to you, cuddled with you on the couch and put its head on your lap. This would be an emotional resolution and consolation, even though your stated goal was not achieved. Greg was so right about this, and it was so funny the way he put it. You know, Greg, his body of work is characterized by these sophisticated endings where the
我解雇了你并把你送回家。你带着痛苦回家，并没有完成你的目标。但你的家庭宠物狗向你走来，在沙发上跟你依偎在一起，把头放在你的膝盖上。这将是一种情感上的解决和慰藉，尽管你既定的目标没有实现。格雷格在这点上太对了，他表达的方式太搞笑了。你知道的，格雷格，他的作品特点就是这些成熟的结局，在这些结局中，
character does not get what they think they want, but still gets what they emotionally need at the end. And it's part of the reason why I'm so grateful to have worked on this show and worked with Greg Daniels, who taught me so many priceless lessons about storytelling. Oh, Jenna, we both feel like we know Greg. We've known him a long time. But when I hear these stories from the writer's room, it's this whole new perspective on Greg. And man, I am just more and more impressed with him in how he can convey a thought or
角色没有得到他们以为自己想要的东西，但在最后仍然得到了他们情感上真正需要的东西。这也是为什么我很感激能在这部剧工作，并与格雷格·丹尼尔斯共事的原因，他教给我那么多关于讲故事的无价课程。哦，珍娜，我们俩都觉得我们很了解格雷格。我们认识他很久了。但当我听到编剧室里这些故事时，我对格雷格有了全新的视角。天哪，我对他的印象越来越深刻，他如何能传达一个想法或
explain the dynamics between human relationships, and he's so flippin' smart. It's so true. And it is such a sophisticated way to tell a story. I mean, they've written songs about that idea. You don't get what you want, but you get what you need. Yeah. And that is what happens in this story. Yeah.
解释人际关系之间的动态，他真的是聪明得要命。太对了。而且这是一种非常成熟的讲故事方式。我的意思是，人们围绕这个想法写过歌。你得不到你想要的，但你得到了你需要的。是的。而这正是这个故事中发生的事情。是的。
It's so layered. Pam and Michael heal one another and give one another what they need. Yeah. Yeah. Someone to say, I'm proud of you. And someone to show Michael, I guess, what the power of a piece of paper is. That's what he says. It's so sweet.
它太有层次了。潘和迈克尔治愈了彼此，并给予彼此他们所需要的东西。是的。是的。有人对她说，我为你感到骄傲。而有人向迈克尔展示了，我想，一张纸的力量是什么。这就是他说的。太温馨了。
Well, and also just to be appreciated, Pam really appreciated that he came there. And it's a reminder for Michael that, you know, business is people and you can't cancel people. That's right. We had a question from Amber, Julie, Aubrey, and Rohit. Did anyone end up keeping the picture of the office that Pam made? Yep. Me.
嗯，而且仅仅是为了被欣赏，潘真的很感激他能去那里。这也是对迈克尔的一个提醒，你知道的，商业就是人，你不能把人开除。没错。我们有一个来自琥珀、朱莉、奥布里和罗希特的提问。有人最后保留了潘制作的办公室照片吗？对。我。
We talked about that in Casino Night with John. Yes. That I got to keep that, and I have it hanging down in my entryway of my house. And a little thank you to Phil Shea for making that happen for Jenna. Well, we wrap up this episode finding out that Ryan has not lost his job, that Michael has just moved him to the annex, which is such a punishment, because now he's going to have to share a desk pod with Kelly. And Kelly is so excited.
我们在《赌场之夜》中和约翰谈过那件事。是的，我保留了那张画，我把它挂在我家门厅的入口处。顺便感谢菲尔·谢伊为珍娜促成了这件事。嗯，我们在本集的结尾发现瑞安并没有失业，迈克尔只是把他调到了附楼，这真是一个惩罚，因为现在他必须和凯莉共用一个办公桌隔间。凯莉太兴奋了。
She's so thrilled. And here's a little tidbit from the DVD commentary. Brent said he went into Mindy's office and he said, Mindy, here's the scene and he pitched the scene to her. And she began to just improvise as Kelly how Kelly would respond to this news. And Brent just wrote it all down verbatim. So he was like, he said Mindy is so great at channeling Kelly that you literally could go in and pitch to her a Kelly moment and she'd be like, oh, she would totally say this.
她太激动了。这里有一个来自DVD评论的小花絮。布伦特说他走进明迪的办公室，对她说，明迪，这是这个场景，然后他把这个场景讲给她听。她开始即兴发挥作为凯莉会如何对这个消息做出反应。布伦特就把这些原话都记了下来。所以他说明迪非常擅长演绎凯莉，以至于你真的可以进去向她抛出一个凯莉的时刻，她就会说，哦，她绝对会这么说。
I love that. Well, we had some fan questions about this. Haley, Fortuno, Jillian, Audrey, and Mariel all asked, was Michael moving Ryan to the annex as a punishment, a way to get Ryan back out of the bullpen so that he wasn't as visible and could be in the writer's room some more? I'm sure. Yes. Yeah.
我太喜欢这个了。嗯，我们有一些关于此的粉丝提问。海莉、福图诺、吉莉安、奥黛丽和马里尔都问，迈克尔把瑞安调到附楼作为惩罚，是不是为了把瑞安从大办公室调回来，这样他就不会那么显眼，并且可以多在编剧室待一会儿？我敢肯定。是的。是的。
Because now our three writers were all back there, Paul, BJ, and Mindy. No, it was very smart. Well, Jenna, there are some deleted scenes. You know, in this episode that are really fantastic. I haven't talked too much about them, but there are two that are sort of interesting. And I thought I'd share a little bit with you about that. And we had some grand questions. So here's the first one.
因为现在我们的三个编剧都回到了那里，保罗、BJ和明迪。不，这非常聪明。嗯，珍娜，有一些删减片段。你知道的，这一集里有些片段真的很棒。我没有谈论太多，但有两个片段有点意思。我想跟你们分享一点关于这方面的内容。我们有一些粉丝提问。所以这是第一个。
And Ryan Moberly, Jamie Kearns, Allie Giancarlo, and Jamie Miller all wrote in and they said, in the deleted scenes, Karen attempts to rip down Pam's art show Flyer in the kitchen. All right. They say, I know there are so many people that say that Karen didn't deserve all of this hate because her only crime was not being Pam, but can we please discuss? Yes. So what happens, Angela? Okay.
瑞安·莫伯利、杰米·卡恩斯、艾莉·詹卡洛和杰米·米勒都写信说，在删减片段中，凯伦试图在厨房里撕掉潘的艺术展传单。好吧。他们说，我知道有很多人说凯伦不应该受到所有的这种仇恨，因为她唯一的罪过就是她不是潘，但我们能讨论一下吗？是的。那么发生了什么，安吉拉？好的。
Well, Karen is in the kitchen. There's a Flyer for Pam's art show and she looks around and she reaches up to grab it to pull it off the wall. And then I think Oscar walks in and she just quickly just leaves. And we don't really know anything more than that, just little glimpse. But you know, everyone, everyone in the office knew about it. I don't know that she was being that vindictive. Maybe she just wanted to see the details.
嗯，凯伦在厨房里。那里有一张潘的艺术展的传单，她四处看了看，然后伸手去把它从墙上扯下来。然后我想奥斯卡走进来，她就迅速地离开了。我们除了那个小片段之外真的不知道别的了。但是你知道的，每个人，办公室里的每个人都知道这件事。我不知道她是不是那么怀恨在心。也许她只是想看看细节。
But you could say maybe she didn't want Jim to see it. Maybe she didn't want Jim to want to go. Maybe she wasn't being vindictive. I mean, she was going to take it off the wall. I think this was a good cut because I don't like the side of Karen. I'm glad that this was cut from her story. Me too because Karen was already so vilified. She didn't need to lean into it, you know?
但你可以说也许她不想让吉姆看到。也许她不想让吉姆想去。也许她不是怀恨在心。我的意思是，她本来要把它从墙上拿下来的。我认为这是一个很好的剪辑，因为我不喜欢凯伦的那一面。我很高兴这个从她的故事线中被剪掉了。我也是，因为凯伦已经被妖魔化得够厉害了。她不需要刻意去迎合这个，你知道的？
Yeah. So I think that was a good scene to have deleted. Now here's another deleted scene that Kate Flannery and I talked about and Susan Lewis and Kyle Meeker wrote in and said, there's a deleted scene where Meredith is telling Oscar a joke about Pam and Roy. The joke is almost all bleeped out. What was the joke? Oh, no.
是的，所以我认为这是一个很好的被删减场景。现在这里是另一个删减场景，凯特·弗兰内利和我谈过，苏珊·刘易斯和凯尔·米克尔写信说，有一个被删减的场景，梅雷迪思正在给奥斯卡讲一个关于潘和罗伊的笑话。那个笑话几乎全被消音了。那个笑话是什么？哦，不。
This is like us doing laundry and betrayal. I know. I know. So I said, Kate, what was that all about? I went and watched the scene and the deleted scene is Angela's in the kitchen and Meredith is in there and she's like, hey, why did Pam leave the wedding with Roy? And I'm just like, would you stop it? And I leave the kitchen.
这就像我们在洗衣服和背叛。我知道。我知道。所以我说，凯特，那到底是怎么回事？我去看了那个场景，被删减的场景是安吉拉在厨房里，梅雷迪思也在里面，她说，嘿，潘为什么要和罗伊一起离开婚礼？我当时就想，你能不能闭嘴？然后我离开了厨房。
I am not going to entertain this. Then Oscar comes out of the bathroom. Meredith goes, hey, Oscar, why did Pam leave the wedding with Roy? And Oscar's like, Meredith, I'm not going to get into this. I think gossip is like harmful. And then Meredith can't even contain herself. And she starts to tell the rest of her joke. And she kind of does a gesture with her hands by her crotch area.
我才不理这茬。然后奥斯卡从洗手间出来。梅雷迪思说，嘿，奥斯卡，潘为什么要和罗伊一起离开婚礼？奥斯卡说，梅雷迪思，我才不掺和这事。我觉得八卦是有害的。然后梅雷迪思简直控制不住自己。她开始讲她笑话的其余部分。她一边在胯部附近用手做着手势。
And it just is like, because Roy, bleep, bleep, bleep, bleep, bleep, bleep, bleep. And then Oscar's like, gross. And Meredith cackles and says, I know, and leaves the kitchen. And Kate said, Kate said that in the script, all it said was, Meredith tells an off-color joke to Oscar. That's it. And it didn't say anything else. Is that true, Jenna?
然后就像是，因为罗伊，哔，哔，哔，哔，哔，哔，哔，哔。然后奥斯卡说，太恶心了。梅雷迪思咯咯笑着说，我知道，然后离开了厨房。凯特说，凯特说剧本上写的只有，梅雷迪思给奥斯卡讲了一个下流笑话。就这样。没有别的了。是这样吗，珍娜？
Yes. I checked the script and it says, Meredith has one scripted line. And the script says, Meredith says, Roy, then long bleeped sentence while gesturing in an unusual way, ambiguously, that could be totally nasty or could be something quite different. Hard to tell, really. There's no visible lip flap. And then the script says, Oscar says, that's disgusting. So I said, Kate, do you remember what you said?
是的。我查了剧本，上面写着，梅雷迪思有一句台词是写好的。剧本写着，梅雷迪思说，罗伊，然后是一句长长的被消音的句子，同时用一种不寻常的方式做着手势，含糊不清，可能真的很恶心，也可能是完全不同的东西。真的很难说。没有可见的唇部动作。然后剧本写着，奥斯卡说，真恶心。所以我说，凯特，你还记得你当时说了什么吗？
And she said, no, I don't remember. She said, but you know, I remember I just wanted to try to shock them and my dad owned a bar in Philadelphia and so I just tried to throw out some of those bar jokes I had heard. Oh, I love that. I love that. Well, guys, that was business school. Yes.
她说，不，我不记得了。她说，但是你知道，我记得我只是想吓吓他们，我爸爸在费城开了一家酒吧，所以我只是试着说出一些我听过的那些酒吧笑话。哦，我太喜欢这个了。我太喜欢了。好吧，伙计们，这就是商学院。是的。
Thank you so much to Brent for sending in audio clips and Kate as well for telling us everything about that bat. Yes. And I also want to tell you guys, Brent is an amazing teacher. And he's currently teaching an online class called Writing the TV Comedy Script. It is such a bargain. So if you have, like, an idea for a TV pilot or a TV show that you've been dying to write, you have to check out this class.
非常感谢布伦特发来音频剪辑，也非常感谢凯特告诉我们关于那只蝙蝠的一切。是的。我还想告诉大家，布伦特是一位出色的老师。他目前正在教授一门名为《编写电视剧喜剧剧本》的在线课程。这真的是太划算了。所以如果你有一个电视剧试播集或者你一直渴望写的电视剧的想法，你一定要来看看这门课程。
You can find it at BrentForrester.com. Well thanks, you guys, so much for listening. We hope you have a fantastic week. Yeah, we'll see you next week for some cocktails. Ooh. Oh, Jenna, one last question for you. What? You know what Pam's art show was called?
你可以在 BrentForrester.com 找到它。嗯，非常感谢大家的收听。我们希望你们度过愉快的一周。是的，我们下周见，喝点鸡尾酒。噢。哦，珍娜，最后一个问题问你。什么？你知道潘的艺术展叫什么名字吗？
What? Artists for art. Did Roy write that? He did. We'll see you next week, guys. Bye. Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies.
什么？艺术家的艺术。是罗伊写的吗？是的。我们下周见，伙计们。拜拜。拜拜。感谢收听“办公室女士”。
Office Ladies is produced by Earwool, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher. Our sound engineer is Sam Kieffer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubacow. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
“办公室女士”由 Earwool、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的副制作人是艾斯利·巴巴科夫。我们的主题曲是克里特·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。想要收听无广告版本的“办公室女士”，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用 Stitcher Premium 一个月，请使用代码：Office。这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可发表评论。